not muted themselves go ahead and mute
themselves and we will begin this work
session of the Public Works committee
where we will be hearing um
presentations by various agencies of the
state before we
begin as chairman of the house Public
Works and highways committee I find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the
covid-19 pandemic and in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this body is authorized to meet
electronically these are presentations
pertaining to the capital budget please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and a select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during the
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website this notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
911-a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
27136 or email
HCS
lg. state.
n.us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled I would
like to introduce the staff that are on
the meeting assisting us Brad glean uh
committee researcher and Christopher
Shay of the legislative budget assistant
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let us start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there's anyone
in the room
uh with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to no law Mr
clerk if you would call the
role thank you Mr chair uh
representative
Graham I'm in the committee room with
other
members representative
mcon representative
mcon he will be leate he's got seconds
so great representative Mills I am here
uh my wife is somewhere in the house uh
representative
samaro yes I am here in my office
conference
room representative
fidie representative
fidi representative
Newton yes I am here in my house and my
wife is in the house
representative
blazic representative
blazic here
sorry representative
boards representative
boards representative kazinski
uh here and my wife is in the house
also representative
kolansky I am here and traveling but
we'll be home alone
shortly representative
Thompson present in the
room representative Vanda
Castile representative Vanda Castile
representative cluder uh yes I'm present
in the committee room with other
committee
members representative Edgar present at
home my wife's in the house on
Place representative
eel representative
eel representative Jack
representative
Abbott I'm here in the committee
room representative
fauler I'm here at home in Swansea my
wife is in the other
room representative
Newman yes I'm here in the room alone my
husband is in the
house representative
Eaton representative Eaton
representative
Peterson present at home
alone representative
query president uh at home
bunker present at home my wife will be
in and out of earshot
[Music]
sorry about
that Mr chairman we have 17 members in
attendance and have a
quorum uh thank you and I will remind
committee members that this is being
recorded and you can watch it later on
YouTube if you so desire and that forums
while not necessary for uh hearings for
presentations or work session are always
helpful um with that we will dive right
into the first presentation which is
from the state
treasurer uh good morning uh thank you
Mr chairman and members of the committee
uh again for the record Monica mapelli
uh state treasur and with me this
morning is also um Rachel Miller um
she's um our chief Deputy Treasurer so
between the two of us uh we'll try to
answer any questions you may have um as
you know I I was um presented um a few
weeks ago um um to you and I uh at that
time we spoke about um you know the
various tools that we use to uh evaluate
uh data affordability and so today um um
I know I provided um a couple of slides
for you so I'm going to share my screen
in a moment um so just U one second
where I locate
that oh it has been disabled I'm not
sure if I'm going to be able to do
that oh yes
okay there we go perfect um
um very good can you see my screen now
yes we can yes very good thank you um
so um again a few weeks ago I I we
shared um similar slides so this are
going to look familiar to you but what
we did for today's presentation is uh we
updated the numbers um so what you're
seeing today is is a preview of our debt
affordability study that we are
currently working on in we hope to issue
the final report by the end of next week
um so today what we're going to do is is
just highlight a few of the key metrics
um that we pay attention to and um again
we we we spoke about this a few weeks
back so I would like to focus um you
know to your attention today to the debt
to revenue ratio as you may recall this
is the ratio that we use U this is the
metric that we use the most to assess
debt affordability and it's also the the
metric that the rating agencies use um
to evaluate Bond insures um when they're
assessing U the financial health of the
state so um just this updated numbers
what uh for example in in fisc year 20
what that shows is that our debt to
Remer ratio which is um the last line in
the slide is um so for for fisc year 20
the debt to runer ratio went down to
6.7% since our last estimate I think
last time we we showed you that it was
um we were estimating it was going to be
um about
6.8% um now the the in the next slide
I'm going to show you in a minute um
is is showing that in FIS year 2019 the
the metric was 6.4% so clearly um and
FIS year 20 the number changed um for uh
really the the primary reason is the um
the revenues um the revenues decreased
compared to fiscal year 19 and that's
what caused the ratio to increase to
6.7% our estimate was higher it was 6.8%
so the good news here is that revenues
um for fisc year 20 came in stronger
than originally anticipated so uh we
were able to adjust that in in in a a
better number
so um the next point I would like to
make is um if you look at fiscal year
21 um the ratio is going down and is
going down to uh a very uh uh goodlook
number is 6.2%
um the reason for that is also um that
revenues are
um based on the estimates that we hear
from Department of Revenue it looks like
the revenues are going to come in um
stronger again than what was original
anticipated so what we did in our
assumptions here is we only adjusted
Revenue by a decrease of 2% which I
believe that's what they're anticipating
for uh for revenues in fiscal year 21 um
so we included that in the
calculation but this the the the the
main point of this change really is um
the in last December December 2020 we
issue bonds of
um um we had a new issue of 47 um 47
million normally uh we we issue
approximately 60 million each year and
that's the typical
um bonding authorization that we
calculate for this study 120 million for
the vium 60 million for the fiscal year
so in fiscal year 20 we only needed
approximate 47 million and that's what
that's the amount that we issued so with
less debt being um incurve we borrow
less uh our number went down the other
reason is that uh we were able to refin
we we did two refundings
um so we um so with those refundings we
we generated some savings and and again
the thatb service was reduced and and
with that the calculation um it shows
that the ratio went down to 6.2% so it
is a very goodlook number that's the way
we would like to see it unfortunately um
things change for fiscal year 22 and the
point that I want to make in 22 is
uh in this calculation we are uh we are
we are considering that we're going to
issue approximately 60 million in in new
money bonds but we're also including um
the um the possibility of issuing
additional 50 million which relates to
the PFA
remediation uh project those are bonds
already
authorized and uh we don't know the
details of how those projects are going
but um there is a possibility that we
will end up issuing an additional 50
million for uh the FIFA remediation
project so with those two amounts of
ratio and fiscal year 22 increases to
6.7% and um of course that service at
the point increases so then uh the
following years um the ratio is looking
a little bit higher overall uh we
continue to say that this are uh this
are good numbers
and um you know despite the the changes
and the assumptions that we're making um
they continue to show that the Le the
levels are manageable so with that um I
think the question that you know that
you're that you want to hear from me
is we we still we still want to
recommend 120 million in bond and
authorizations um that's the number has
that has been recommended over the last
few sub few fiscal years so just to be
consistent we'll continue to recommend
that and we're just showing you the
numbers based on those authorizations so
we know for example that I believe the
governor's budget has 130 million um the
legislature May recommend different
amounts um those are policy decisions
that uh you all will have to discuss and
and determine what's the best approach
um to follow um again we feel like our
job is really to provide you with the
tools and the numbers so you're able to
determine um you know what is the best
approach um so those are the numbers I
don't I don't want to get too deep into
the numbers um happy to answer any
questions I think the next slide with um
with this next slide show is is um again
you're familiar with what be presented
to you before um the
the the 10% really is a warning level
that we essentially if we have reached
that 10% on the debt to rer ratio we've
gone too far the uh the rating agencies
would like to see that um you know that
will put um
that for for variet reasons um this is
we're just right now we're talking about
um um debt levels um due to um bonds
being issued but we also have other uh
obligations the state has other
obligations uh pension obligations opep
obligations and and all of that is of
course considered as part of the overall
health of the state so our goal really
um is going to be to try to maintain the
de to reel ratio um um hopefully uh
lower and and maintain it that way to be
able to show that again to be consistent
with the states that policy um that is
um is managing um their debt levels um
again um this is uh you know one of the
credit positives um that the rating
agencies like to see um it just shows
that we we have the a borrowing capacity
uh to also um you know manage the
current uh projects but also to respond
to potential emergencies if there is a
need to issue to to deal with a
particular um emergency or initiative
that is important to to legislators and
policy
makers um the chart that is in the
middle of the page also shows obviously
the history how the Deb rent ratio has
performed uh over
time um you know back when we were um
closer to the recession the ratio went
up and it was managed uh over time um
during the last uh few
years uh again uh um FIS year 2018
2019 um it was um you know the lowest
number we've had in a while again due to
the pandemic and 20 we went back up but
but it was still we still we still
consider this that we have U manageable
that levels and and and that is really
um how um New Hampshire is recognized to
maintain this this conservative policy
in in his in his really being
praised um the last the last point on
this slide is is just to show you how
much uh we still have of authorized and
unissued um um debt and so we have 174
million that's still that has been
authorized but uh we haven't spent money
on those on those
projects um so with that um I'm going to
ask um Rachel if she would like to add
anything um and after that we will 'll
be happy to answer any questions that
you may
have sure uh good morning can can folks
hear me yes great great
um the only the only point I would add
just to pick up on where what Monica
just mentioned the 174 authorized
unissued
a small portion of that may have been
spent but but it's it's accurate to say
that we have not bonded it so when we
Bond we put together a a project list
and that list consists of uh prior
spending that we're reimbursing
ourselves for and future
projections uh so just just a little
detail but that 174 some of it may
be uh spent you know as we speak speak
but since we only Bond once a year we
scoop up all prior expenses and future
projections um but but no I I happy to
answer any questions again with Monica
but
um great thank you Rachel thank you very
much um mam Treasurer I know you have to
leave L around 10 to go to fiscal
committee as well um that's just for the
committee
um I'm sure we'll ask you back but I do
have a couple of questions if you could
answer them of that
174 million that is out there does that
include the $50
million for the uh pfoa um
remediation or is that on top of the
174 I believe that's included is that
correct Rachel just correct me if I'm
wrong you're abs absolutely right that
includes the
50 um thank you and I I know you re you
said you recommended 120
million um and I assume that that is
what you recommended to the governor as
well and he came in over that um what
does your debt
affordability
um percentage numbers look like at the
130 level versus the 120 for the next
for the
foreseeable um future as youve laid out
in one of these
slides yes thank you for the question it
really doesn't change the ratio it
really Remains the Same and again just
to be consistent with with what we have
the treasury has recommended um we like
to utilize the 120 million and and and
and show you the numbers to to really
show you what that does um but we we we
we change the number to 130 million it
really doesn't change the ratio um again
I think for formality purposes we we
continue to recommend that 120 million
but a change of five million upper down
it really doesn't change the
number okay and and I'm sure at some
point um members of the committee will
ask what if it goes more than you know
five or six or it goes to the one 35
million level or something like that but
I'm not going to ask you to speculate at
this point um we can handle that when
the questions come up
um yeah I was just gonna add I think I
think when you start seeing real changes
are when you start adding 50 million at
a time and and again I think as you saw
and and when we added the the the 50
million um of the pfa's remediation
project that's when we start seeing
changes of half of a percent in in and
so those are those those again
additional five to 10 million is really
not going to change the calculation is
really when you go about that is is when
it becomes a little significant and th
uh our debt levels will increase at that
point thank you because I remember when
I asked two years ago that very same
question about well what if it goes to 6
point whatever percent and and the the
number was huge to that you had to do to
to do that so I just wanted to get that
out there um any other members of the
committee representative
Jack
than the of La extension in this budget
the amount of La extension in this
budget is substantially more than what
it normally is which means that we're
not retiring as much by the as we
normally would assum you've taken that
into account as
well I'm very sorry I couldn't I
couldn't hear the
question the am the amount of laps
extension in this budget is
substantially more than what it has been
in past
budgets and that means that not as much
bonded indebtedness is getting retired
as would normally be retired I I would
assume you taking that into account in
your
recommendation yes all of that is taking
into account we are we are in in the in
the in the Deb um de affordability study
we include um you know we assume the new
debt that we are be initiative each year
we also remove the retire debt and and
we also um you know the the final study
is going to show you um it's going to
show you additional um sensitivities
that that we prepare we we include uh
stay guaranteed um that the state is um
guarantees for um the business Finance
Authority for for um um for peace so you
will see um you know all of the
sensitivities that we include in that
study so it's a more robust
comprehensive study so the the basic um
case base that we call we we do include
those are the basic um um you know
components of the calculation adding the
new debt um retiring and paying off the
debt and how we are able to um again the
state's policy is that we try to pay 60%
of the debt um in the first 10 years and
the other 40% in the other 10 years so
it is a it is a conservative um um and
beneficial way to pay off debt and and
again all of that is included in the
calculation representative
fer yes thank you for than the question
looking at the ratio of Debt Service to
revenue could you explain what Revenue
goes into the denominator and how
sensitive changes in tax revenue might
be to that that
number thank you great question it is
unrestricted Revenue uh what we use so
any changes in revenue and decreases in
Revenue will impact um will impact the
ratio any other members of the committee
either in the room or ending remotely if
you're attending remotely if you would
um hit the uh raise hand button it
really helps us rather than you sitting
there waving your hand especially if
your video is not
on seeing that uh Madam treasur and uh
Miss Miller uh appreciate your coming I
imagine that we will be asking you to
come back later once we get a better
feel for where the committee is going
on um this capital budget and
so I appreciate um you're taking the
time this morning to talk to us and um
I'm sure we'll be talking again in the
future thank you thank you Mr chairman
it is a pleasure have a great everyone
all funed
fiscal thank you thank you thank you
all right um time being C your Mike
watch 9:59 we have 10 o'clock with the
governor's budget director but since
these are simply presentations I think
we're going to go straight
into um the presentation from the
budgets director and uh Matt if you
could uh
talk about the priorities that was used
by the governor and his office and
establishing who got what in the capital
budget if you could start there it would
be
appreciated thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee it is great to
be with you all this morning I'll be it
virtually um and I look forward to your
questions on the governor's capital
budget as introduced uh and also thank
you to uh state treasurer
State treasure state treasurer mapelli
for her presentation this morning as
well um you did note Mr chairman the
governor's budget as introduced does
exceed the recommendation of 120 million
um but we do not expect uh any more than
nominal impacts uh based on the debt
affordability analysis the treasury has
conducted uh and we do feel comfortable
at the level that we've put forward uh
as you can see from the materials that
the LBA has provided the committee the
governor does recommend $17 million in
new general fund Capital
Appropriations this combined with the
Appropriations that were delineated in
hb25 from 2019 uh for the 2223 bium
bring that total to $125 million in
general fund
Appropriations um one thing I do want to
note is this budget
includes $40 million in IT projects
which is uh somewhat higher than we've
seen in the past and I think this
underscores the state's commitment uh to
making sure that the state and state
employees have the resources uh
especially in light of covid and our
aging it infrastructure systems uh to
make sure that we can continue
operations uh even in light of a
pandemic and these issues are things
that have come to light in past year and
projects that were prioritized to
address that
need uh additionally um as I'm sure Mr
chairman you know and for the benefit of
other members on the committee uh there
is one erroneous appropriation in hb25
and the materials that you have relative
to the Hudson CTE Center um as this
committee has put forward uh legislation
last session outside of
hb25 that did fund uh that $2.5 million
appropriation for that project that was
originally scheduled for FY
2223 um what I will say about the
process is that these projects have been
scored both by administrative services
in the department of it uh where
appropriate uh and through our
consultative process identifying the
greatest needs for the state whether it
be to ensure that our systems are secure
um or ultimately providing those most
essential
Services uh we did put forward a
pre-selected list of projects uh which
is what you see in the 2021 Capital
Improvement plan booklet that I'm sure
you have all received and then from
there working with each agency having
detailed conversations about those
projects where the areas of greatest
need were uh and funding as many
projects as we could uh at a level that
we felt comfortable putting
forward of course course this budget
can't fund every
request but we have prioritized those
projects that either have the greatest
return on investment uh address critical
needs have the longest useful life um
and that's what you see before
you one consideration that I do want to
point out for the committee our ongoing
conversations in Washington DC regarding
potential money uh for state and local
governments uh ultimately those
conversations have not factored in to
hb25 as presented given the timing uh
that we don't have certainty that a a
bill would pass or B what the Contours
of that bill would look like but that is
something that this committee will have
to address if and when uh a potential uh
legislative package does move forward in
Washington DC and if there's money that
is flexible for one-time infrastructure
projects here in the state of New
Hampshire um given that timing there is
one appropriation in House Bill 2 that
would prioritize those federal dollars
and that is for the forensic hospital
that was originally partially funded in
House Bill 4 uh from
2019 and we have carried that forward
into uh House Bill two as
introduced uh this year as well one
other note that I do want to make that
currently exists in House Bill 2 but may
be more appropriate to shift to House
Bill
25 is a lapse of capital Appropriations
relative to projects at the department
of safety and what the department has
brought forward and I'm sure they will
have additional conversations with the
committee as well is to reappropriate
those laps dollars to complete the state
police hanger project uh jointly with
with the Department of military Affairs
and veteran services uh so just wanted
to make sure that the committee is aware
um of that in hb2 which I know is not uh
formally introduced from OS at this
point in
time um just to comment on on some of
the questions just one question on House
Bill two on the psychiatric
hospital inhouse bill two as as the
governor has sent it to the legislature
and we'll see it eventually um is that
bonded money and if so how much is that
bonding for so that question and I think
the language will make this clear once
it's released uh essentially would
prioritize federal dollars if those
federal dollars become available it
would be the intent to pay for that
project in cash the way we had made
original Appropriations two years ago um
but it does include a provision that
should uh federal funds not be available
or that the department cannot identify
other options to fund that
appropriation it would fault or default
back to a a bonded Capital appropriation
um but there are several conditions that
that would come into play before we get
to that point Mr
chairman oh and the total amount I
apologize if I didn't mention that is
$17.25 million
were you were you finish with your
presentation or I I you at that point
but no worries Mr chairman the only
other thing I would mention um the
lapses and one of the representatives
had a various St question given covid we
have seen some capital projects get
shifted um or continue to see extensions
um that an important consideration for
the committee and it's great to hear
that those questions are already being
raised uh for the treasurer um and
similarly we do see an opportunity given
the low cost of debt where we are today
to make strategic
Investments um while staying within
those thresholds that have been
identified by the rating agencies and
even though we do exceed that $120
Million number we feel that the market
conditions are favorable to make those
types of Investments today while also
knowing that there may be one-time
Federal money on the horizon um but
again that's a question that that the
governor's phase really couldn't address
because of the ongoing uncertainty there
but with that I'm happy to take any
questions from the
committee I I have one and it deals with
um the community colleges as well as the
University system when I look at the
numbers that are being proposed for both
of those um systems it looks like all
you have done is give propose giving
them the money that was promised in the
last uh bium in House Bill 25 of
2019 is there any
reason um that you cut it off at just
well we'll give you what we promised
before
um and leave it at that um rather rather
than looking at uh current needs as
well thank you for the question Mr
chairman and it's great to be talking
about the university and the community
college system because obviously our
commitment uh to those systems as they
exist today and as the governor has
proposed in his budget to unify the
boards in year one of this bium and then
combine their funding in year two um
that is certainly something that did
factor into our
conversations uh not to say that there
aren't emergent or new needs that have
Arisen past uh the Appropriations that
were made in fiscal year 2019 but given
the size and the magnitude of what we're
proposing to do with the boards we
wanted to make sure that those decisions
could be made by that unified system as
they weigh their priorities
um in a unified manner as opposed to
each independent board or system
bringing forward those recommendations
so that is certainly something that came
into our conversation um there may be
opportunities for the committee to fund
some of those projects that were
presented in this cycle um and some of
them do have Merit but it is important
to consider that when we talk about
unifying the boards and merging the
systems some of those factors do need to
come into play
um and this is a hypothetical if that
unification does not happen then both of
the systems
have lost two years of Capital
Improvements by uh we hope this happens
is that not
true I I would say that you know there
are considerations to be had there Mr
chairman I think we're confident that
those conversations will progress and we
really do approach this as an
inevitability that these are Alles that
systems across the country are facing
and rather than wait for that crisis to
manifest itself we want to do this in a
strategic Manner and given that if it
were not to happen it is true that two
years would have gone by but weighing
the pros and cons of that approach
versus the opportunity that really does
exist um coming out of this opportunity
to unify the systems we see that as a
stronger benefit that will put that new
combined New Hampshire college and
university system on the best footing uh
going
forward questions from other members of
the
committee um I see no hands raised
either
um I do have one other um I thought
somebody would ask it looking through
here um how much of the goal was also to
maximize um Federal matching funds for
for all of these as as you presented
there you know in De the military and
Veterans um the veterans home all of
those have um federal dollars that are
that can be matched or or are totally
Federal how much of that entered into
your factor of what projects got uh
approved or not approved at at the
governor's
level thank you Mr chairman and that's a
a great question to consider and
certainly something that did come into
our scoring uh the opportunity to
leverage out outside dollars uh to build
projects I think that as you mentioned
those agencies also places like HHS um I
will say there are projects that were
proposed that would have leveraged
federal dollars that did not make it in
um to the governor's uh version of the
capital budget as introduced uh one
notable project would be uh the Canon
Mount Tramway uh which would leverage
federal land and water conservation fund
uh monies um so that is not included it
would be an opportunity to further
leverage those funds um but certainly a
factor that we we did consider Mr
chairman
any any other
questions May you're really getting off
light
today but I'm sure that you will be back
at some point as we begin our our
deliberations on what to include or not
uh include in the in the governor's
proposal or changes there too the final
question that I have because I've heard
from
couple of agencies already about we want
to make changes to um the governor's uh
proposal how closely did
you as the budget director work with
agency heads or their staff to make sure
that they understood what was going into
the capital budget before it was sent
over to the
legislature uh so we did have
conversations uh with agencies
especially projects that the governor
had further questions on beyond the
detail that was provided uh in the blue
booklet from Das um I will say uh we
didn't have a conversation with every
single agency especially if their
projects were either well explained
initially um but we do understand that
changes do happen and then some of those
priorities have shifted and I'm sure
you'll hear from some of those agencies
today um so we have heard from those
agencies as well uh we certainly want to
support their requests um as presented
and were appropriate uh consider and and
work with them on what their revisions
might be um and to your point Mr
chairman I'm more than happy to come
back anytime the committee does have
questions um but I do appreciate a light
first day so thank you all for that
there is still time to change that I
will
say see no hands raised either in the
room or those attending uh
remotely um I thank you Matt and I'm
sure that we will be talking um
especially as we start making changes
and you want to know what we're doing as
well as the governor I'm sure um and and
there will be questions I know about
thinking uh and most of those should be
answered by the agencies but we shall
see thank you Mr chairman thank
you all right for the members of the
committee I have 105
1014 um our next presentation is not
until 10:30 and is Department of
Information Technology and as you just
heard from the budget director there's
$40 million of it work in this budget um
which is why he is the first one up for
the agencies because it cuts across a
lot of the agencies but um the house
does work on schedules and we have a 15
minute break before um the commissioner
of oit
um comes on so with that we'll take a
brief break uh remember people that the
bike is always live
thank
you
us
e
e e
that
there he
is gets
back it's a work
loely I already made a note when I sat
Down's
PRI I didn't see anything
[Music]
the time 10:30 if everybody could mute
themselves if you're not
speaking
um and we will begin with the Department
of Information
Technology um I see that the
commissioner is on um
so welcome to Public Works and highways
commissioner oh good morning Mr chair
and and members of the committee um for
the record my name is Dennis goule I'm
the commissioner for the Department of
Information
Technology um I'm hoping that the um
presentation materials that that we sent
out um are are in your
hands I believe most of everybody got
them um if not they can find them at the
lb's web
page so I'll jump right in um starting
on the second page we have um three
items that that we're requesting for
this this period um the first one is
cyber
security
um and the second one is for cloud
services and the third one is for
continuity of operations and Disaster
Recovery planning I have a page a
summary page for each one so I will move
now to P page
three and our first priority which is a
cyber security program
enhancement um if you look back to
previous um capital budget requests
we've been
requesting um capital for cyber security
um each banm I think this may be the
fourth bium in a row and sadly I don't
expect that to change uh the the the uh
bad guys keep getting better at things
and we keep having to adapt so um we we
have some new initiatives uh that we're
looking at um this year looking forward
I should say to the next
uh couple fiscal years
um one is uh the first item is to um we
we've enhanced some of our tooling um
with the with the last um budget request
in the last banian and that allows us to
to get deeper into what's happening with
our applications from a cyber security
perspective and um so what we're what
we're doing there is um number one
really is is going deeper into the
number of systems that we're able to
Monitor and
analyze keep track of how data is being
used and whether it's being used
correctly or misused so it's kind of a
high Lev view of that I could really I
could probably spend an entire hour just
on that one bullet in terms of the types
of things we we would be doing um but
I'll just give you a small example there
um we're actually right now for vaccine
management we are looking at log file
data that's created by the systems and
analyzing that data to look for bad
things happening we know that we've
heard from the um um from our federal
partners that there's there's credible
threats that um you know the um folks
would uh folks who do ransomware would
try to monetize by taking down
vaccination systems so we be out Extra
Care on that particular thing and we'd
like to expand that in the next bium to
many more important systems in the state
um second item is really um improving
the way we um we validate and identify
users across the state systems so that
we do it in a in a much more secure way
um in a much more consistent way across
systems um and then finally um we during
the early days of the pandemic we did
Implement um New Edge uh Computing
equipment to deal with the fact that um
we had lots more people working remotely
we had to upgrade all of our equipment
unexpectedly and we did put in a new um
intrusion protection system or
prevention system IPS and we implemented
it basically as we had our old system
but the new system has much more
capabilities than the old one and we
want to invest in making sure we're
using those
capabilities to to the greatest extent
possible so uh so that's um that's item
number one um I will now um I think uh
it might be easy to stop for questions
on each item if that works for the
committee so I will um I will I will ask
the committee now if there's any
questions on item
one um thank you commissioner I do have
a comment
question from CHR
[Music]
theba thank you repm Graham um I was
only going to offer to share the
presentation on the screen if that's
easier for members and for the
commissioner or they could share their
um document if they would like it to do
it
directly just wanted to put that out
there if that would be
helpful I I'm having head shaking yes
here in the committee so if you could do
that it would probably be
helpful all right hold on one moment and
that's okay with you commissioner goule
or did you want to have either you or
Ken do it no no having you share it that
would be great Chris thank you very much
okay so everybody should see um priority
number two I think that's where you're
we're headed do you want me to go back
to Priority number one well let's see if
there's any questions on priority number
one
okay all right hearing none I guess we
can go go to Priority number two I had a
question oh
excuse yes yes commissioner goule
um does your under under item number one
do you does your department have
anything to do with developing the
state's vaccine registry
um we're we're involved in that with the
Department of Health and Human Services
and public
health
yes I'm sorry could you repeat your
answer um we are involved are you
talking about the um the scheduling
system or the immunization management
system or
both I guess um I don't know the the V
I've been asked that question several
times by people um that's why I'm
bringing it up I believe it has to do
with the authorization that came last
year to get it developed and the
specific question to me was who's doing
it and when is it supposed to be
finished oh okay I think I know what
you're talking about now that would be
the I believe that's the immunization
what they call the immunization
information system or IIs and that is
actually being implemented as we speak
by public health and there um that and
that was funded in I believe in I saw
the contract go to governor and Council
I think about a year
ago thank you you're welcome other
questions on um item priority number
one representative
Abbott thank you Mr chairman I just had
a question
um it says in this information that the
life expectancy in this project is 10
years is is that realistic or is in fact
it should be a shorter time
period um is that a question relating to
how we would Bond the the debt for
capital
or no it just says the life expect oh
yeah I mean yeah typically we put up a
new system system um we would expect to
run it for about a decade because it's a
pretty big investment and you need to
leverage it over a period of many years
so I I think that is realistic for the
most part yes I mean the stuff the cyber
security measures that we put in place
um you know a decade ago um most of them
are still operating today it it's a
layered it know we don't unfortunately
cyber security is you know we keep
adding layers and we never we never
remove them because we always have to
you know there it keeps getting more and
more difficult to secure our data and
protect ourselves so we just keep
layering on more protections over over
time so yeah I think it's
realistic representative
fauler yes thank you I think my question
is similar to representative Abbott uh
perhaps it would be help us understand
how much of this in investment is going
to purchasing out equipment or outside
services and how much of it is to
fund um you know
full-time uh you know state employees
they
have okay thank you for the question
none of it is to fund
employees um it's all for um we have a
relatively small cyber group um and we
do sometimes uh for example last time we
uh the last by we funded a a
comprehensive cyber risk assessment
which we did with outside Services which
were which was completed um recently
actually and so so zero for state
employees thank you you're
welcome seeing no further questions if
we could move on to the next item
so um this this item is um during the um
during the pandemic we accelerated our
implementation and use of technology to
run the business of the state and it's
really been helpful um we um using cares
act money we implemented um the
Microsoft um
cloud-based um collaboration suite at
the E3 level which I believe is what
both the um both the legislature and the
um and the courts are using as well um
and we did it very quickly mostly to get
teams up and running so that the state
employees could collaborate and it's
really helped a lot um but but we have
much more work to do there to fully
realize that investment um the the
licensing for that is is in the 2223
operating budget and it's about
um depending on how you measure it's
about um $3.8 million a year operating
expense this is this would be for
products and services to
enhance um what we've already
implemented and make sure that we get
the full leverage out of uh that
operating expense
investment um the other
um and um what we're seeing now is a a
great demand in inside state agencies to
leverage you know now that they've had a
taste of this technology um and they
found the the U um you know the
improvements in Effectiveness that it's
given
them um there's a great thirst to
continue and and fully leverage the
tools so that we can um benefit the
state even more particularly at this
time when we are so res we are resource
constrained um from the standpoint of
Staffing so um and again this is this
none of this would be for state
employees this would all be for products
and services associated with um uh cloud
services and digital government services
and when I say digital government that's
projecting capabilities out to Citizens
um uh to
uh to provide the services that we might
have t typically provided um in
person any questions on item two
seeing
none
on so now we'll go to Priority
three um so in in the previous
bium um um there was funding for um a
beginning to um work on improving our
disaster recovery and continuity of
operations plans um I've I've actually
they've been
requesting uh that for um number of
banians and I believe last bani was the
first time we got some funded um the
state of New Hampshire does not have a
very good um core Disaster Recovery plan
for it systems so in the previous vium
uh we funded a a analysis um and I I
think at this point now we're we're
about to or already have awarded a
contract
to have a company come in and study and
analyze our current Disaster Recovery
capabilities and make recommendations
for the for what we should be doing in
the future this um as we had planned as
the follow on to that which would then
begin to act
on the findings of the outside study or
the outside analysis of our Disaster
Recovery capabilities and what I mean by
that really is that our ability to
should we have a a physical disaster or
some other thing that causes our data
center to to be damaged we want to be
able to bring up critical State Services
as quickly as
possible today we have a very small
relatively small Disaster Recovery
capability for our Core State services
but it's in conquered which is
absolutely not best practice because you
know say we get a big ice storm that
takes out all of conquer that would take
out our main our main
capabilities as well as our um as well
as our backup capabilities so um and and
uh yeah I just got an update from my
Deputy Ken who says that U you where
contract is going to GNC soon on that
phase one so this is this is a follow on
to that um and I think it's really
important for the state particularly um
now as we're seeing all the more and
more weather events that are more and
more severe um you know I get nervous
that that we don't have this uh
capability in
place any questions from the committee
on this
one I'm seeing none and no hands raised
from those who are participating
remotely thank you okay um so the next
thing I'd like to cover is you know we
have we we I just shared three of our
Capital requests with with the committee
but you'll see lots of other technology
Capital requests coming before you and
um now I wanted to share the process we
go through and and many times I've been
asked um you know do you do you
collaborate with the agencies as they
develop their um their capital budget
requests the the answer is definitely
yes and this is the process that we
follow uh so the U you see the kind of
the three main
steps um that we look
for um the um step step one is really
the initial list um developing the first
round of testimony in the in the
governor's phase and then we do we do uh
vetting of all the projects you know is
it
duplicative is there uh or uh or is
there maybe there's already a capability
that the agency didn't know about um
fundamental life cycle considerations is
it time has has the previous system been
fully
leveraged um or maybe in our case um is
it Pastime like we see we often see this
uh ptime for example the Department of
Revenue is implementing a new Revenue
information system replacing a 30 plus
year old system so that clearly was
Pastime from a life cycle perspective
um is it in alignment in other words we
work on during the budget planning we
work with every Agency on their AG their
their strategic technology plans it's
called aitp or Agency information
technology plan and you know so we have
an expectation that their plan their
strategic plan and their Investments
would align with each other and if they
if they don't something's really wrong
there so we look at that um and then we
we go down even more granular um
criteria and if um and you can see that
at the bottom of the page step three
criteria so you know how important is it
you know is it um to the state overall
and is it an Enterprise or agency impact
so so um you know obviously something
that has a broader impact than just the
agency might be you know might be um
more heavily weighted than something
that's simply just for an agency um
is it in alignment with key things that
we think are important modernization of
government reducing complexity for you
know for citizens to access um their
services and then transparency you know
we like to you know you know
transparency is part of our information
technology plan so we certainly like to
make sure that we are at least and
keeping that as transparent as is is now
or more transparent from a from a
service and a financial perspective then
there's the feasibility and risk stuff
organizational Readiness so so um if a
if an organization for example is asking
for
funds um but they aren't properly
staffed to implement that that might
signal that they're really not ready and
that there needs to be more um focus on
getting the staff ready to implement and
so investing in something like that that
might not be appropriate um and uh and
legal and or political considerations
and that that you know there are things
that there are a lot of because we're in
in government there are a lot of
considerations that go into a system
that go beyond just the pure technical
or business process stuff that you you
normally see in the private sector U so
we look at that as well and of course we
look at security um and that's that's
from from a couple of perspectives one
is you know the keeping the data
protected um um but also compliance with
the many standards that we have to um to
live within most of which are
promulgated by the federal
government um but some are not like PCI
for example payment card industry
standards we must be in compliance with
those and and so we look to make sure
that the project would be would be able
to to to at least remain compliant or
improve our compliance posture and then
finally we look at Financial
considerations um including um you know
cost reduction Revenue
generation uh you know of course some
agencies don't generate Revenue but many
do and then um leveraging alternate
funding sources for example in in you'll
see a lot of Health and Human Services
projects that are on the list um and
while they're they tend to be you know
pretty large and costly projects they
also have a lot of federal funding
leverage so that tends to that tends to
make them appealing both from the
standpoint of leveraging alternate
funding as well as a lot of those
projects tend to be focused directly on
citizen service so so those are the
criteria we we look at um when we're
considering the projects and we we share
our views with the governor and that's
how you know he uses you for the most
part he'll use what we're what we're
thinking about with respect to those to
make his recommendations when he passes
his proposed capital budget and if we go
to the next page page seven you will see
the the list of of um projects that um
that the governor um had had approved
that from the requests that were made U
by the agencies and one call out the the
priority column that's the agency
priority so you know in the um almost
six years that I've been in manhan and
state government I've seen that what I
call technology density increasing that
is more and more technology being used
for more and more things and the other
thing I'm seeing is that the
prioritization of these projects has on
average has been increasing within the
side the agency so when you look at how
many um agency prority ones there are in
there um it's you know it's pretty
striking or even twos and threes so
there's there's quite a lot of um
there's quite a lot of um you know high
priority for the agency
projects and the rest is is just now I I
will call out that um there's a a dncr
um Communication System replacement
project in there oh yeah the number is
right there that could get increased I
thought maybe we had the old number the
original ask for that project was more
like in the 400,000 range now it's up to
700,000 that one since I mentioned it
that's I I'll use that as an example of
of how our the the analysis we put
projects through it work because as we
were looking at at um in the previous
vium as we were looking at um dnc's need
to upgrade their Radio Systems we also
knew that department of safety was
upgrading their radio system so rather
than doing it twice
separately we connected dncr and
Department of Safety so that um dncr is
now going to use uh the the core system
that department of safety implemented
and is
implementing um to save the state money
and and also um since safety has a lot
of expertise with these kind of systems
that they're actually able to help dncr
with their staff reducing the
implementation costs for their for DNC R
's new radio system so that's a nice
concrete example of how the analysis and
and the collaboration with in between
agencies that we we Foster during the
process actually help save the state
money um so um that that concludes my
formal testimony um I'm happy to answer
any and all questions that you may
have um thank you
commissioner
um I have one and it's more of a request
um you're obviously the first of many
agencies that going to come before us
over the next month or so and based on
past
practices some of them will come in with
additional projects that they want to be
funded if it has to do with
it would you be willing to take a look
at them and do a quick fetting of them
to make sure that they fit into um what
you just explained to is your process
for
recommendations we absolutely would
thank you representative
Mills thank you Mr chair Mr chair I
think you took the uh my question right
out of my mouth that that that was
basically my entire concern here uh you
know the past years we've gotten so many
so many it requests from different
departments and our our major concern
has always been have they been vetted by
the IT department and do you guys
actually know what's going on and it
appears that with this system I think uh
our minds are a little bit more set at
ease so that we can we can be assured
that all the budget requests have been
vetted by you
guys that that is true um we spend a lot
of time on this and and honestly what
you know my process and is to try to
improve at every VI Anyan as well so we
always reflect on when we're going into
a budget season both from a capital and
an operating budget perspective we like
to reflect on what we did last time and
try to up our gain each by Anyan in
terms of how you know the level of
information and level of discipline we
try to apply Financial discipline and
business discipline so um that's
something I care a lot about
particularly in the you know you know
because of the public nature and and the
fact that we're you know we're taking
monies that we collect from citizens and
and and spending them I think it's
really important that we we be really
smart and transparent about
that um there is one more thing once
when the questions are are complete
there was one more thing I wanted to
mention to the committee um before we
close so I'll just let's let the
questions continue I'll cover one more
thing if I may um I do have other
um member who would like to ask a
question representative
fker thank you um commissioner gulay for
your testimony I'm new to the committee
so I just wanted to ask quickly um this
chart this final chart that summarizes
all the different Department's requests
how does it compare to the last couple
of years is it pretty much in line with
or does it bump up or down and if so
briefly why well that's a great question
question um so the we've the quantity of
requests that I've seen over the Bia
that I have been in state government are
about the same each year from a
technology perspective what varies
greatly this year is the amount that the
governor decided to fund from technology
versus other uh this is I think it's
almost double what was what was funded
by the governor or requested to be
funded by the governor in the previous
bium
and so I think it's a recognition of the
you know the importance of technology in
our citizen service Mission certainly
we've seen in in Co that you know a lot
of the things we've been able to get
done um would not have been done had we
not had the right technology in
place I see no other hands raised
commissioner you said you had
a final
comment yes um so there was language um
added to in 2021 to hb25 we actually
didn't request the language but it
turned out to be very helpful to us in
covid um from a flexibility perspective
and and and I'll read it to you and I
canot send it along as well if you wish
uh the commissioner of the Department of
Information Technology is authorized to
reallocate funds on among the projects
in in sub paragraphs blah blah blah blah
as it was in House Bill 25 as necessary
to complete the projects so we you know
we didn't ask for that language and um
but it would turned out to be very
helpful um during Co in the sense that
we could um you know um we could be very
responsive on the digital government
side helping out in various places to um
particularly in in the digital
government space but so I would I would
ask I I can forward that language along
to Chris and I would ask the committee
to consider adding similar language in
this in this time in this case if you
would well commissioner we don't have a
copy of House Bill 25 at this point it's
still being drafted but if you could
send that
along to to me I'll make sure that uh
the committee sees it and we give it due
consideration
um and it may be included in what the
governor has proposed I I just none of
us have seen the final language of what
the Govern well it's it ended up in the
previous
banians um House Bill 25 in 2021 and and
it it was a pleasant surprise for us
when we saw it there and I'm not sure
how it got in there but um I wanted to
just mention it and fact that having it
was was very helpful to the state
any further
questions seeing none commissioner thank
you and as I mentioned earlier if
somebody comes in with something new we
will be in contact I I'll be we'll be
ready to respond
immediately thank you
much the time being
11 um we will hear from the Department
of military Affairs and vetan Services I
believe the adant general is there
welcome General
M hey thanks sir uh thanks for having me
having me uh for the record Major
General David mtis the ad general for
the New Hampshire National Guard in the
department of military Affairs and
veteran services um which list are you
going off of sir just so I make sure
when I run down the list I'm in sync
with
you I'm going by what the uh Governor
proposed all right so I will go down the
list of what the governor proposed and
then if it's okay with you I'll go
through some of the items that were not
funded that we would like consideration
of all let's go through in that order um
I'm not sure if you heard but we've
heard from the treasurer already um
additional funding for any agency is
going to be very tough right um and so
you're you're at the start um but you
may not get much more if um if anything
more Yep so understood um so first if
there's a new representative out there
um just to give you context for us our
department um uh when you look at the
funding General funds versus federal
funds generally speaking and being very
simplistic we have two types of
buildings our armories which you see 17
18 of them throughout the state which
typically have a 5050 federal state cost
share then you'll see our Aviation
facility in conquered you'll see some of
our maintenance facilities in hookit
Rochester conquered Hillsboro those are
100% federally
reimbursed so you look at the cost here
for some of our specific projects if
there's a state cost share it typically
affects our armories for us to sustain
them if it's 100% Federal um it's just
you know competing against federal
dollars trying to get the money into the
state and just then fixing or
refurbishing some of those federally
reimbursed
facilities so we got on the laundry list
of the six items that were approved in
the governor's cfal budget um item one
is called anti-terrorism Force
protection Mar County and sir that's the
first one on your list correct
correct yes okay
so that had a 7525 federal state cost
share um that was for our Pembrook
facility where we have both a 100%
federally reimbursed facility and an
Armory we acquired five acres of of land
contiguous to our existing parcel in
order to do Force protection measures
like fencing um curbs some parking um
that was a 7525 federal state cost share
of which we can do some of those uh
Force protection enhancement
improvements on based upon this new
partial of land that we
purchased item two energy resiliency and
and efficiency Improvement Statewide
100% Federal 3.5
million in simple power lants is fixing
boilers uh doing Energy Efficiency
measures being aspirational maybe doing
a micro grid trying to improve the
Energy Efficiency of our 100% fed
reimbursed
facilities item three Grafton County
field maintenance shop it's just a big
maintenance garage 100% Federal so we
compete in the president's future years
defense plan is fep um for large
military construction projects in
federal fiscal year 23 we will be
building a new 13.7 million fi main shop
up in
Littleton item four minor military
construction Coos
County this is aspirational this is how
we can try to compete for additional
Federal resources and bring trying to
bring them into the state of New
Hampshire so we will compete in the
future years um for a minor military
construction project through their
presidential budget process to try to
get additional funds to build in
addition to one of our armories or a
maintenance facility up in the north
country
country item five min and Military
construction straford County trying to
replace some of our Barracks facilities
our dormitories um again aspirational
competing for federal dollars to try to
replace outdated Antiquated facilities
that are 100% failly
reimbursed item six Warehouse facility
upgrades marac County trying to move our
federal Warehouse from Rochester to to
Franklin and enhancing and renovating an
existing building and then changing that
facility in Rochester another
Armory simply put those are the six
projects that were
approved I would like to address one
change that I addressed in a memo to the
committee and that's changing item one
anti-terrorism force protection marac
County we would like to move those funds
to 4 $15,000 of General funds to another
priority
project the reason why is because prior
subsequent to us submitting this budget
submission National Guard Bureau
approved of an exception to policy to
allow us to utilize 100% federal funds
on this specific
project so those
$415,000 of General funds we would like
to move to a general Readiness Center
um project Statewide that allows us to
replace roofs and boilers at our armor
Statewide so those are the six items
that the governor's Capital project were
approved that is the reason why we want
to move those General
funds what do I now like to address is
what we didn't get and I understand
trust me with 800 soldiers and Airmen
activated throughout the state in covid
another two to 300 soldiers Airmen
employed we understand the uh the fiscal
environment that states
in we're our organization assumes risk
um is the fact that none of these
projects provide us any general funds
for our 17 armories throughout the state
of New Hampshire for the next two years
when our oldest Armory is 1880 our
Manchester Armory is 1932 and the rest
of our facilities are Cold War era
facilities both in the 50s and 60s 0 to
17 armories that total 400,000 square ft
of office space there's a significant
amount of risk there we do not have any
funds in the current budget to replace
any roof leak or any boiler
failure those same armories are being
used for PPE warehousing and
distribution we use them for covid
testing we're using them now for
vaccination
support um that's our Challenge and
that's why I'd like to discuss two
project s that are not in the governor's
budget that we are sort of uh asking for
your support
for sir would you like me to continue
then with those two two items go
ahead so there's two items um you know
that were not funded that had a cost
share right a 5050 cost share one of
them was titled Readiness Center
renovation Statewide 1.2 million 600,000
General funds 600,000 federal funds 5050
State cost share that 415k we would like
to be moved into that
account that it will allow us as a
minimum to at least replace one roof and
one boiler during the next two
years the it other item that was not
addressed in my memo to you would be to
ask the uh committee's um you know I
guess leniency or support on getting
what's called Energy resiliency and
Energy Efficiency Statewide
so I discussed the one that was for
buildings that are 100% federally
reimbursed but we also have another
project of the same name and topic for
our
armories that was 1.75 million 875,000
General funds 875,000 federal funds any
funds in that account would be
appreciated um you know bottom line for
us is it's a great budget it's a great
start it allows us to sustain our
federally reimburse
facilities it does not not allow us to
sustain our 17 armories throughout the
state which with an average age of
1950 uh subject to your questions is
really all I
have any
questions representative Thompson you'll
have to speak up make sure that the
mic's catch
um item four in Coos County one of your
aspirational projects we're in Coos
County sir it's most likely going to be
Berlin um we had to make a decision in
the North Country we have two armies up
there in Lancaster and Berlin
uh lack of recruiting lack of
um resources we decided to close our
Lancaster Armory and transfer to the
Hampshire fishing game
and we will keep Berlin Armory and we're
just looking at you know aspirational
trying to get additional funds to
sustain that in the long
term thank
you do I see any other question I have
one General on moving you do not need
that 415,000 that was there for the
antiterrorism at maram County if we were
to move adust that into
um what you were talking about the 1.2
million if we give you 4115 can you
match that with federal funds of 415 and
get something done or is that just all
on us no we can match it that's what I'm
telling you any dollar you give us in
general funds will be matched at least
by one to one or uh 7525 so uh you know
that's the challenge for us is um
you know if you think about it uh we
have 70 to 80 buildings uh just under a
million square feet of office space
3,000 soldiers and Airmen plus or minus
and uh almost everything we do has a
federal match so any dollar you give us
is going to be matched uh you know so I
mean yeah we'll double down so any
dollar you give us is going to be match
with a an equal federal state federal
match
and and just so that as we're looking at
if we were to go along with any of this
recommendation it would be um titled
ready to send a re renovation
Statewide um whatever the the general
fund and then the federal fund matching
as well yes sir
yes thank
you
um representative
El uh yes thank you Mr chairman uh I'm
just going to go on record as saying
that when we do when we start uh
discussing this in committee and we do
our little up and downs on everything
I'm going to make the recommendation to
add on to that 415,000 to bring it up to
600,000 for the uh for their original
request for priority number four uh
that's that's less than $200,000
and and in a budget decize I think it
will be well spended thank you Mr chair
thank you representative Mills if you
could convince um 12 people on this
committee to go along with you we will
do
it any other hands
raised see
none oh representative Edgar I missed
that
unmute yourself
Mike thank you uh thank you Mr chairman
I see that there's a difference between
what we received in February and the
great big bound book we got in
December um it looks like maybe some of
the priorities changed uh do you have
any comment to that uh
General Sir what I think happened is we
proposed 10 priorities
uh five of them with a uh general fund
match and I believe what transpired
through the governor's budget is they
they funded six of our 10 projects so
that's what I'm assuming is the
difference in um the the listing
priorities between the past and the
present chairman was am I
correct um pretty much um if you look at
um the as as one of our members tells it
the wishbook that went to the governor
the the blue the blue book that we all
have and what was actually in his
proposal sent to us you'll see that many
agencies the the listing is different
but the projects are all right um so I'm
not sure if it was just um the staff
going okay we're gonna do all six and
just put them down in whatever order
they they wrote them or what but they're
all there so okay um and I'm not sure we
didn't ask uh the budget director if the
the priorities that are in the
governor's proposal or the governor's
priorities or
not okay if I could just uh if I could
follow up please
sure thank you um there was also a land
listed originally in the uh the blue
book that we got did but the totals are
the same and the other items are the the
same was there anything unusual about
that did you get the land some other way
no a Ser we'll accept the risk um
usually what we'll do is every budget
cycle or every other budget cycle we
usually put in it's the state's
responsibility to provide us with land
so we can build new
armories we understand in the current
fiscal requirement asking for a half
million dollars of General funds with no
federal match probably isn't going to
work and
so with prior bium budget freeze
releasing some funding we have remaining
from Land um that should be sufficient
for us to use uh use and try to get
after what we need you know so you know
why we need so much some of these
General funds in this current budget
cycle when I tell you that you we have
17 armories and zero funding for them
for the next two years I can look the te
leaves and tell you that two years from
now
um if you and I are still here I will be
asking you for my number one priority
will be $5 million of General funds to
match a $15 million um Federal Armory
that we're going to be building in
2027 so I you know so like we're always
trying to you know get the land today
for five years out and what we'll
essentially do is you know with funds
that were're just released uh um from
the current budget frees we will use
those to get the next sort of future big
milcon project to bring them to the
state so that's why we it was our number
one priority then Co hit then we said
you know what this this won't work so
that's why we I'm not advocating for it
right
now Mr your hand
up it was um represent Graham all I was
going to do was just uh help clarify
some of the various documents that
people may have looked at or maybe have
in front of them um and if I could if I
could just share my screen from moment
sure and representative bunker I I do
know your hand is up so so right now
you're looking at um this is the summary
list from the what I would call the the
the fat binder from the June meeting
where the capital budget is presented
for the to the
governor and in that um you had 10
projects for the Department of military
Affairs and veteran services and those
are listed here and you can see the land
you can see the reference to number four
that the um General was me uh discussing
of these 10 projects that were there in
June seven made it into that blue bound
book that you were mailed the it's
called 2021 Capital Improvement
program and during that process there
may be some adjustments to the amounts
that you see in that book compared to
this page that I have on the U in on the
screen because the uh Public Works
division within administrative services
will look at the various projects and
try to um get a better handle on what
the cost might
be and then the last piece that you have
right now is the recommended Governor's
capital budget which is that gray thin
book and in there there were six
projects for the for the department so
the the land one is um was identified
did not make it in there so I just
wanted to um you should have all of
these documents I emailed you um the one
that you have on the screen here it it's
the capital Improvement requests revised
25 June
um it's got every agency and all the
projects they listed back in
June so that if you need to if there's a
reference to that today from another um
department or going forward um that's
one place you can look if it's not in
the blue book so that's all I just
wanted to help the committee with that
um and I know the general was
referencing a couple projects in this
and I just wanted to make sure the
committee knew to look at that um
document thank you Mr sh uh
representative bunker did you have your
hand
raised no I think maybe that's left over
from before thank you I just didn't want
to um miss
somebody any other questions for um the
agend
general seeing none thank you very much
General
for being here thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for supporting the men and
women of the New Hampshire National
Guard
and once once again I thought there be
more questions or more requests from the
Department um we have 10 minutes
before um the next presentor which is
the New Hampshire Veterans Home
um
so take a
break a
minut
e
e e
to I I would ask that um you check your
email
um because a lot of the documents we
have seen so far this morning were
emailed out by uh Mr Shay from the lbaa
it was all in one email um so that we
could look at them ahead of time um as I
said in my email to everybody um there
is just no way that they're going to be
able to
um uh snail mail all of these documents
out to everybody I understand that the
CH are quite lengthy may not want to PR
them at home but you can either read
them on your own screen or Mr sh's GNA
jump in here and explain where else they
are thank you ripson gam they're also
located on our
website um if and I can walk the
committee through that um if you would
like just so you can see where they
are why don't we wait until
after yep after we hear from the veteran
home um so we're not C I don't think
she'll take the full half hour no that's
fine
representative about one more
minute yes
sir for
I
have um
11:30 and I call the meeting back to
order and the next
presentation is from New Hampshire
Veterans Home
welcome good morning uh Mr chairman and
committee members thank you so much for
allowing me to present to you today the
needs of the New Hampshire veterans home
over the next bium um for the record my
name is Margaret Le and I'm the commant
of the New Hampshire veterans home um as
you can see from my presentation and
from the governor's uh capital budget um
there are two vital needs at the New
Hampshire veterans home at this point um
the parking lot repairs and
infrastructure although it may not sound
like um a needed project truly um is our
um mission to make sure that our staff
and visitors are able to get into the
Veterans Home in a safe manner currently
we have many uh cracks and um divots
throughout the parking lot area that
makes it um very hard for our um
visitors especially those who are
handicapped to transverse into the
veterans home um and we have areas
throughout the um area it's called the
lot e that is an unimproved dirt parking
lot that during winter time many of our
staff need to park out there in order
for the other parking lots to be cleared
of snow and
debris and um to pave that would add to
the security and safety of them to get
into the building um so I um in the
parking lot just walking around it you
can tell I walked around it with the
public works uh gentleman when he was um
here it happened to be raining that day
and literally you would see the water um
just puddling around the building and um
where the cvet was almost two inches
above where the pavement is um creating
trip and um fall hazards that we feel
that absolutely needs to be corrected
and so we um look for your um support on
that
item chairman would you like me to go
forward with the next the master plan or
would You' like me to break for any
questions are there any questions on
this
say
n thank you uh again the Master Plan
update um our last master plan was done
in 2010
2011 and um so we would like to make
sure that we are updating our designs
and definitely the needs of um the
long-term care facilities throughout the
state as you know with the health and
safety guidelines especially with the um
the current pandemic we want to make
sure that our building is as safe as it
can be and so um with a master plan
looking towards what our veterans will
need in the future as well as any
changes that need to be that need to
occur throughout the building to ensure
that we are providing a safe um and
secure building um for our veterans in
the
future thank you I do have one question
about that one and maybe the other one I
I know that the VA helps fund part of
your operations yes sir is there any
potential for us being able to use
federal funds for either of these
projects um my review of the regulations
that support um they they support
building repairs um I have not found a
regulation that allows um land repairs
for federal
support and a master plan so
comes what they to have I would hope
that they would help pay for it um I'm
going forward I will definitely look
into that especially where um the
pandemic comes into place I would um
definitely submit this forward um if the
monies were secured on our end um they
do require that the general fund portion
be secured um prior to their
approval thank any other questions at
the com
Thompson um com what is the size of the
parking lot you're proposing to
re um I do not have the square footage
directly in front of me I will tell you
it it's
approximately um the land that we are
currently using is almost two acres and
that parking lot circumferences the
whole building um and goes um we have I
I wish I had the numbers I apologize I
do not have the number of parking spots
or the square footage it may be um that
I can get back to you on that um I can
get that
information um also where did you come
up with the uh with the cost uh Public
Works is um was the our guidance on the
cost just for for your information we
will be hearing from administrative
services this afternoon all of virtually
every project not every project goes to
administrative Services early in the
process for them to look at the scope of
the project and to provide a funding
number to both the governor and to us as
we go forward by and large the agencies
do not come up with that dollar amount
unless it's something that is mandated
in law or federal
rules thank you uh represent
bunker thank you for taking my question
commandant may I just ask um how does
this list of two items that the governor
approved compare with your original
request um it's exactly the request that
we
had thank you thank you representative
Newman yes thank you uh comment down on
the on the um your master plan update is
that done by do you go out to bid to you
have someone do it or is that an
internal document um that's taken care
of ma'am by
either that would be put out to bid but
and a consultant would come in in
conjunction with the um the staff in
this building as well as stakeholders
externally um but it's done by a
consultant thank
you any other question
Mr chairman did you want me to speak to
those items that I asked to have
extended uh I do have a question
repres nice to see you
again a general question heart goes out
to Veterans your
staff yourself we turn the corner with
your
facility and we had better times now
with Co on the
proper I'm sorry Mr chair could you
repeat that so I can't hear
him thank you com I just said it was you
um m is on the facility the veteran
staff have have we corner there with
covid at this point are we at a place we
were a month and a half yes sir we're
very fortunate that we have turned the
Corner um Public Health did declare the
outbreak closed on January 26 as uh you
guys may know um that started on
November uh 10th we had held um covid at
Bay for two and a half months
unfortunately it came in it came in hard
um we had our last positive uh veteran
at the end of December last positive
staff member mid January and so again um
our outbreak has been closed we are
clear and we are covid free at this
point we are uh moving forward in the
phases as public health allows and
Community spread um to allow for outside
visits now um outside visits not being
truly outside of the building but um
having family members able to come in
and uh keep a social six feet diff
distance from their loved one as well as
masking and um the sanitizing area so
that they're ABS able to visit although
I will tell you that during this
pandemic we have done everything that we
can to ensure the connection between
families and their loved ones whether
that's through Facebook Skype um
messenger uh iPads uh computers um and
window visits so that um families are
able to um communicate with their loved
ones thank you uh thank you for you and
your St thank
you
see um on the new capital
Appropriations the did provide us with
some information about lapses of
previous
um Capital requests um and in order to
save some time for representative jacket
is committee as long as we have um 20 or
30 minutes today um we can go ahead and
answer those questions and it's one less
Agy that we have a later
um go
ahead you want me to go ahead with the
um extension request sir please okay so
um we currently are in the midst of the
firewall repair um and I don't know if
that's the first one on your list or not
um that
is is what you said okay thank you so as
you can see the first first three
bullets are items um that we thank you
very much for your support in the past
those projects are completed and so
those remaining Appropriations although
small um can be and will be lapsed in
this um end of this fiscal year um and
will be coded as such the first project
that I have um is the building firewall
repairs was originally 1.4 million uh
currently stands at approximately a
little under 1.3 now that is the
firewall that needs to be repaired into
the Leo portion of our building and as
you can see that that's almost 2,000
linear square feet of um
repairs um once that is done we're
hoping that our contractors will be able
to get back into the building now that
the community spread is down and those
repairs can be completed if that project
is completed by the end of June that too
and all um expenditures made we will uh
lapse those funds as well and coat it to
close the next one I have is the heat
pump equipment replacement and as you
know um our Leo building and the tar
buildings is aging the um geothermal um
placement um of approximately 146 of
these heat pumps um over the years we
have many that um are failing due to
their life um useful life cycle having
long passed uh so we appreciate um and
ask that those funds are able to go
forward as well I will tell you
contractors have been in areas that are
non-residential when they're able to to
do any kind of the work that they can um
we at this point are still not allowing
them into residential areas um but we're
hoping that going forward within the
next month that with the community
spread continuing to decline we'll be
able to have those uh contractors in the
building and um have those fixed um the
last item that has been a long-standing
item is the Leo third floor Edition um
that has yet to be um approved on the VA
side so it has not um I would call
bubbled up on their
queue and um I believe approximately
three $300,000 have been spent on the
design of that building uh with the new
covid it may be something that we would
want to look at and see if that truly
still um stands as the most current
design that we should go forward with I
will tell you they are all single rooms
and have single bathrooms which is
something that has was um recommended as
we have gone through this pandemic um so
that is one of the pluses of that
addition we would move away from two
veterans in one room and the veterans
would be able to be individually and
single uh single rooms which we have
found um is beneficial to the uh spread
of
infection and I will stop there sir and
um answer any questions you may have
any questions from the
committee see
none and that's it com that thank you
all I appreciate your support for our
veterans in the state of New Hampshire
and for everything that you do for us
have a great
day thank you thank
you Mr Shay yes sir
so I just wanted I'll take you through
to our website so that the committee
knows exactly where the documents are so
I'm going to do a screen share
again so right now you should be seeing
the general court
homepage if you scroll down and on the
left hand
side in that column the from the bottom
you see legislative budget
assistant click into that and that
brings you to our homepage for the
legislative budget assistant and across
the top you have home budget division
audit division and about us hover over
budget division in the third one down
that says budget and revenue
documents you click on that and you're
going to see um a page pop up and in the
middle of that page it says operating
and capital budget documents and if you
click into 22
223 you're going to have you're going to
find it's going to have all the
operating budget documents but it's also
going to have all the capital budget
documents and you'll find the capital
budget documents at the bottom at this
time and you're going to see um Capital
budget- house so any document that um
you're receiving from agencies will be
found here um when we prepare a um
comparison sheet for you we'll put a pdf
version of that that up on this um site
as well but everything that you find
here is something that you would have
been emailed from
me so if there's any questions as you go
forward you're like I can't find a
certain document look here or if you
thought you should have gotten an email
and didn't please email me and let me
know um there are some things that
wouldn't go on this like the um summary
document for the uh June work I have not
been able to get permission to put that
on our website
um we tried to get the documents um for
the blue book that be that have that
available um electronically and
administrative Services hasn't given me
permission to post it on our site nor do
they have it on
theirs um so there may be a couple of
documents as you go through the process
that don't end up on the website but for
the most part everything should end up
here um you have a meeting scheduled
next Friday
you should get an email from me on
Wednesday at some point during the day
and that should have all the documents
I've been able to acquire from the
agencies that are scheduled to meet on
Friday my effort will be to try to get
you things at least two days before you
have a meeting scheduled um a lot of
that has to do with when I received the
information from the
agencies for today you have everything
that um was provided the department of
administrative Services is scheduled for
this afternoon um they did not provide
any documents and that's why you don't
have anything from them so um I will try
to make a note of that in future emails
that you know here's the documents we do
have and these are the agencies that
have indicated they won't provide
something if I know
that so hopefully this is helpful but I
I know working with Ways and Means and
in capital budget and trying to navigate
our website um sometimes it's a little
confusing to find some of the
things um also understand this is the
first year that we're really putting all
the documents that you see down here
actually on the website and we're doing
that for finance we're doing that for um
Ways and Means as well so there's a lot
of information that we're adding to our
website and we're trying to get better
at organizing it as we move
forward so happy to take any questions
um I'm going to stop the screen
share but I think most importantly is if
if there's any questions that you didn't
receive something please email me and
and let me
know
um I see no hands raised um thank very
much Mr Shay um
welcome at this point um we come back at
one o'clock for admin services and if
you look at the governor's
proposal there is a lot in that um
so please be back at one if it all
possible and we will go over
um their presentation in the order that
it was laid out in the
governor's uh
proposal and with that we are in recess
until 100m
today
e
e e
so should be able to
yeah
okay
e
e e
it's up I I would like to uh call this
meeting of the Public Works committee
back into session um this afternoon
we're going to be hearing from
administrative Services they have
several um subgroupings within the
capital budget and um commissioner when
you come on I would I would like to ask
you to briefly go over first what your
agency does in preparation of both the
U capital Improvement program booklet
and then what goes to the Governor from
from that um working group that you sort
of head up and then we will go through
each of the
subgroupings as um shown in the
governor's uh proposal starting for
example with court facilities first and
then just go down the way he laid it out
everybody can follow along on the same
piece of paper
Allen House welcome to public works
again thank you thanks for having me
it's always nice to be here um joining
me one down and one over on my screen
anyway is Karen ramaki who's our
director of plant and property Karen's
going to talk about when we do this talk
about the the projects project by
project
um uh and she'll talk a little bit about
about how we select the projects that we
request um um you know we manage more
than 90 buildings and uh for multiple
branches of
government um and and how we it's we do
our own sort of mini thing and I think
it might be useful for some of your
members to to at least have a refresher
on that and and and how that happens um
to to kind of see the thought that goes
into it and and how we uh how we decide
which roofy leaks which leaky roofs are
um are the leakiest and need the most
work and we'll talk about that let me
talk a little bit about sort of the
process of developing a capital budget
itself um which is I think what you want
to get into um and how it works because
it it I I think it's interesting
um I was thinking this Wednesday uh uh
at the governor and council meeting when
we were talking about a project and we
ended up having a contingency on it that
was like you know $400 and someone said
why is it only $400 and I said because
that's all the money that's left so we
better hit our number um early I'm
looking at a I'm looking at a timeline I
have that that we put together to sort
of help guide us and it gives you an
idea and it's for this capital
budget
um we send out forms to agencies in
February so February a year ago we sent
so more than a year ago at this point we
sent forms to agencies saying get your
capital budget requests in together one
of the agencies that we send it to is
Karen because she sort of she's sort of
that for for this um their responses are
due back to were due back to us April 3D
so what you're looking
at um comes out of requests that were
developed by agencies with a due date of
April
3D a while ago remember that was back
when the pandemic was new and exciting
for all of us um uh and then we go
through a process in June there's a
there's a hearing they're called the
governor's capital budget hearings in
State laww this is governed by RSA 9
somewhere 95 I think um there's a
process about who gets invited who's
there um we typically invite um it was
online this year right because everybody
was scattered to the wind um I think we
invited the entire uh uh Public Works
committee as it was then um some people
were on um some people weren't I see
seem to recall representative cluder
being on it who was the uh uh sitting
chairman at the time um and they ask
questions we go agency by agency and
it's a little bit like the November
budget hearings on the operating side
where everybody's got maybe 15 minutes
to talk about stuff and they go through
their request and what they want well
people request all kinds of stuff and
some of them are emergency items and
some of them are we'd like showers for
the bathroom in the basement of of a
building which I won't name because that
might have been last on my list list of
priorities um I mean not that I don't
think bathrooms are good to have showers
but when we've got a roof that's leaking
um I think we can probably do without a
shower in a bathroom um so that happens
those hearings happen at that point
um the law requires us to make
suggestions to the governor's office and
us us is a US is a funny question and
and in fact when I started somebody said
I said who exactly is us and they're
like they're like I don't know it's Mike
Connor so Mike Connor who was Deputy
Commissioner who retired in 2017 um
although he does some work for us
parttime because he's he's very good he
works for Karen um Karen is in some ways
her successor but other people are in
some ways his successor sorry um and
Public Works is one so what happens is I
sit down with Ted copper um who many of
you know is the director of Public Works
and Michelle Giuliano who's the deputy
director of Public Works um which is one
of our divisions
and we go through the lists and
basically you know at that point and if
you've seen the binders of those
projects it is um some of them are very
thorough an agency knows exactly what it
wants to do maybe I want to build a new
courthouse in Milford um which we
already did but so we're not building
another one but um sometimes they're not
quite as thorough because they're very
much in the sort of early stages of what
they're thinking and so what they think
it's going to cost is
very sketchy because they they haven't
even fully thought it through they
haven't sat down with the project
manager an engineer or an architect and
gone through the process we go through
and we try to rank order those what we
don't know is what the and we're doing
it for the governor um in theory this is
all about the preparation of the
governor's proposal that you have in
front of you the thing that that starts
the process
um basically what we do is we we um I'll
just tell you what we did what we did
this year we go through and we decide
what's an a what's a b and what's a c
because at some point you have this
giant amorphous blob of projects and you
have to try to figure out what they are
we're helped in the process a little bit
because uh Karen who's now way over here
on my screen my Brady Bunch screen keeps
changing um Karen has the most projects
and um and they tend to be the ones that
are more the most traditionally Capital
Budgy not just not just the Das ones but
you know Corrections would fall in that
category too but they do kind of a rank
order in inside themselves going well
you know the roof at you know the the
roof on 27 Hazen really needs replacing
as opposed to the you know if we didn't
do the dairy Courthouse it wouldn't be
the end of the world um that kind of
stuff um and so we use that but we try
to do a little bit of equity and a
little bit of uh you know let's make
sure we're picking at General projects
According to which we think our goal is
to identify health and safety as much as
we can there are political
considerations that we don't make
something might be like well you know
this is the governor's really want wants
to work on a a new secure psychiatric
unit we don't know that and and frankly
if we did we wouldn't we wouldn't judge
based on it because our input is meant
to
be public worky if you will um and so we
do that we suggest
name um suggest to him broad categories
of projects in the past occasionally
people have rank ordered them like one
through 120 which becomes very
subjective and a little goofy um we
didn't do that this year we had broad
categories they then get back to us and
say I want you to estimate these
projects um these are the ones that I
want to take a second stab at so the
giant binder that we prepare for the
June hearing is sort of one take on it
then at the next level when
we're when we're preparing this um which
I think you all have as well the capital
Improvement program book this is not
everything that every agency proposed
right this isn't that's an important
note to make um because in theory the
governor could go off of this list
the
2017 budget debates I was the governor's
budget director I wasn't here um and we
actually picked a project off the list
that was um that was not in this book um
and and I only got wind of it from an
agency we did a we did the library Union
catalog at cultural resources instead of
the archaeology something or the other
because the guy who was running it at
the time really wanted the union catalog
and he didn't understand why we didn't
do it and he was really nice so we did
it um and then I think you you guys even
agreed um anyway so this comes out what
is this these are the projects that so
Michelle and
Ted assign each project Karen says to
them we need to redo the the roof on
Philbrook it's actually not one this
year but um I think it's going to cost a
100 Grand or whatever um it then gets
assigned by by Ted and Michelle to one
of the uh what we call Project managers
at Public Works they're architect and
Engineers we try to assign it to
somebody who kind of knows that area you
know if it's related to a prison Tim
Smith ends up getting it that kind of
thing
um Dave gou does mechanical etc etc um
they then go through an estimating
process where they they try to figure
out if what the agency thinks about its
project is right in a big picture sense
because we're talking about estimating a
ton of projects in a few
weeks um that that Pro that document is
due to the governor um by I think
December 1st so at that point we are we
are producing what we refer to as the
book um or the CIP book and and present
it to the governor in theory then what
the governor does and that this is
happening behind the curtain a curtain
that I didn't look behind this year um
but uh he's then going through that
going yeah I guess that makes sense and
I don't know about that roof and do we
really need four cour houses how about
we just build two and I want to make
sure we do something on this and like oh
you know what we got to do that thing
for the University system that kind of
stuff and so then he puts together a
capital budget but the estimates that
he's using in the capital budget are
coming out of this book um there have
been years in the past where
occasionally
Governors do things with the estimates
like they kind of make up their own mind
um about whether
they were estimated well or not I
believe that this year for the most part
they were um adopted that is to say that
the the estimate that is in the capital
budget comes out of the blue book that
you all have um that's kind of the big
picture
on how we got where we are
today um and I I could stop and answer
questions on that or or maybe jump to
Karen what do you what would you like to
do Mr chairman um are there any
questions on on the process of how we
got to where we are
today see no hands up we'll jump to
where you want to go and if we could as
I said earlier just go down the way the
governor laid it out in his proposal if
we could stop at the end of each of the
sections you know for example at the end
of Court facilities take questions at
the end of each of that rather than on
each project as she's
talking good so I'll let Karen tell you
everything that she knows and and the
advantage there is that she's the smart
one well with that introduction thank
you yes hi I'm Karen rantamaki I am the
director of plant and property um thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
speak today um before I jump into courts
I just wanted to I did did some quick
math
um Das or the plant and property
division of Das I should say because
there's some uh financial data
management projects on here as well
we in our original request um our
projects totaled $73 million so you'll
see that um our maintenance is kind of a
a a tail that we keep chasing um in
terms of trying to get things funded and
trying to get things done um in our
state buildings so with that request
it's um paired down to what you see here
on this list today so I will start with
the court facilities projects um there's
four projects that made the list here uh
the first one Hillsboro County South
which is the Hillsboro County courthouse
located in nashwa um we'd like to
complete a cooling and building controls
project that was started this year um so
we did have some funding uh available to
start that project however
um some of you might recall two years
ago when we requested that funding that
um we were planning to either use it for
Rockingham County or Hillsboro County um
and so was actually a number that was
based on the Rockingham County project
but we were able to use it in NASA and
we were just requesting the remainder of
the funds to complete that project uh
the cooling system uh the existing
system had failed and so it's good that
we were able to get in there and at
least get the project started to get
them some Cooling in that
location um the second project the
Lebanon Circuit Courthouse um has a
failed underground storage tank we're
we're operating with a very small
temporary oil tank right now that has
filled um almost weekly at this point
because there's no room on the site to
put an above ground storage tank that's
large enough to heat the courthouse um
for an extended period of time so we're
proposing to put a permanent tank in and
again locate that
underground um boilers in Portsmith and
Dover are both um over 20 years old um
and and kind of limping along to get us
some heat this winter and so very urgent
that we get those two locations um
replaced and then the final Court um
project actually is for six roofs and we
decided to combine them because some of
them were very um small and we didn't
want to put in a request for a small um
amount of money maybe like $100,000 so
we figured combining those um would be a
a good way to get them all done it also
gives us some flexibility because as
we've seen in the past few years um
Roofing projects can come in really high
over budget or they can come in under
budget and putting them all all six
together in one project gives us the
flexibility to kind of shift money back
and forth between the projects if we
need to um so those are my comments on
the court projects I'd be happy to
answer any
questions any comments on courts I do
have one I note that what was sent to
the governor included we won't talk
about a new courthouse but the the
generator installations that's been a
perennial issue
with the courts as we go through the
capital budget over the last few
bium
um what is the status of of ongoing ones
and where would these go if we were to
approve it by some
fluke great yeah so the original request
um that was put in before my time um
included 10 locations and what we did
last time was we split that into two
projects we said here are the five most
critical um and those most critical ones
were mostly located in the North country
where the temperatures tend to get
colder and we have five other ones that
are um uh closer to the conquered area
we also have some portable generators
which is much easier to kind of move
those around in the conquered area than
to drive them all the way up to Coos
County and so when we split the project
two years ago we did get funding for
five locations um and that project is
finishing design currently and those
installations will hopefully happen in
the coming um warmer season um so that
we're ready for next winter and um when
I talked to my Bureau administrator
earlier this week you know she did say
that these four projects that are that
are um on this list now are our top
priority certainly that generator
project would come in at number five if
we were to get an additional project um
for the court buildings um the fortunate
thing is we we haven't run into any
long-term power outages in this part of
the state um that have affected the cour
houses in the in the recent past and so
that's kind of been working in our favor
we do have the portable units which um
can get us by in one or two locations
but if we have a major Statewide um
blackout then we will have a have an
issue there as
well then you may not have an answer but
there was a separate bill we heard
earlier um this year about a capital
appropriation for digitizing the Supreme
Court Records I'm not sure if that would
follow the court facilities judicial
branch or or where do you have if if we
were to do anything where would you
suggest R Do It um that sounds to me to
be more of a court operations um project
and so I would think that that would
fall under the judicial
branch thank you any other questions on
court
Z that thank you um the next group of
projects here is for a group called
facilities and asset management and
that's the technical term for our
buildings over on the New Hampshire
Hospital campus um that used to be um
Hospital buildings but are now used as
office space for mostly DHHS but also
some other agencies as well um as
Charlie mentioned before um life safety
was prioritized here so project number
one includes four different life safety
projects which include fire suppression
fire alarms um sprinklers where we don't
have any
currently um item two also Life Safety
we had a few um minor incidents which
had led us to um start to investigate
the the old wiring in the main building
um neither one of those incidents were
related to the wiring but we are a
little concerned that um we should do a
full investigation on what types of
wiring are in that existing building and
um start rewiring areas that have
outdated wiring that could be um a
hazard um number three is for the fil
Brook building which we are no longer in
control of but has been transferred to
Health and Human Services for a client
facility um however the sewer line does
need to be replaced it has roots growing
into the piping um so it's it's a matter
of time before it will fail I have been
in contact with HHS and they do want to
move forward with this project so um I
don't want to tell you that it's not a
priority for me um it is a priority for
HHS and I do think that it needs to be
done um item four the their building
again is a roof as Charlie alluded to we
have a lot of roofing projects it's
almost like every two years we're going
to have a whole list of roofs that are
ready to be done so uh there is there's
up this year in terms of um ready to be
replaced and then number five is the old
tunnel system that runs under the uh New
Hampshire Hospital campus um some of
those tunnels are used for pedestrian
travel between buildings they're also
used for utility infrastructure steam um
and electrical um there's some areas
that are not currently used and those
are the ones that are most concerning
because we haven't been down in those
areas very much um as part of the
conquered steam demolition project uh
two areas were determined to be um comp
compromised in that area and we've uh
undergone the process of filling those
in so that um if a car or even a fir
truck were to drive over that area that
it's going to be safe for them and it's
not going to collapse so we'd like to do
a thorough study of the remaining tunnel
infrastructure um and there's additional
funds in there to repair or fill in the
most critical areas that we find during
that
study one question
have is in your uh the
CIP um for that last item it was
650,000 and the government's proposal at
620 which do you
need um the the $330,000 reduction is
not of concern to me um the study um is
probably in the
$100,000 range um we know of one area
near there that needs to be repaired and
we have a quote on that that's around um
low 200 so 225 or so um and the
remaining funds whatever those might be
would be to you know we triage the
remaining areas and get done what we can
get done with the funds that we have
available thank you
anybody else if not just for the new
members of the committee if you could
just really briefly talk about what the
main Bill lead is and what the fair Bill
lead
is used up we know what we're talking
about but just saying main building main
building of what great yes of course um
so the main building was the original
New Hampshire hospital building so if
you're on the campus it's the very large
building with all kinds of wings that
kind of go off the back it's um several
hundred, square feet a lot of it has
been repurposed for Office Space
um some of it is in disrepair and never
be used again um it is a it is a
valuable asset because it provides a lot
of square footage for us to put office
staff in um and it's beautiful old
building it could use a little TLC but
it is it is a nice space um and then the
their building um Charlie probably knows
better than I but I don't I don't know
what the original purpose of that
building but it again a lot of those
buildings were used for either nurses
that lived on on campus or
um you know different services that they
provided for the patients that were um
residents of the hospital so it's an
older um Again original Hospital
building that has now been converted
into office space they is also if you
turn in the campus off Pleasant Street
which is how most of us would get there
and you immediately have to turn go to
your right or left if you didn't do that
and decided to go cross country you
would run smack into ther it's that
building it's the building that all also
has daycare in it and I'm told um I
haven't wandered it um I've mostly been
in the basement because that's where the
that's where the new boilers are but the
fourth floor is supposedly gorgeous with
beautiful Woodwork and somebody said
that's how you can tell where the
doctors
were because they had the nicest spots
and the and uh back in the day doctors
had really nice offices and nurses did
not so just saying yep
not that I'm endorsing
that any I see no hands raised on this
portion Charlie do you want to talk
about the fdm project oh I'm sorry yes
um and one of the things I didn't
mention when I talked about how projects
get done is uh uh some of you will know
that over time um IT projects are slowly
but surely eating up the capital buet
budget um and uh uh I've promised people
that I'm not going to refer to the
capital budget as the real capital
projects and the IT projects because
that's completely unfair um but there
are there are some people who think that
and I might sympathize with them um
Dennis goulay and his staff look at all
the IT projects that are proposed and
try to rank order them based on priority
everybody wants new computer software
right everybody does and everybody
thinks thinks if I only got a new
computer program and I paid two four8 12
million for it suddenly everything would
be more efficient um and that's what I
thought when I upgraded my phone and it
didn't work um the this project is for
New Hampshire first New Hampshire first
is is what's known as an Erp ENT
enterprise resource planning it is the
computer it is the computer system that
is on everyone's desk and it is where
all of the stuff is kept all of the
state's financial management all of the
states HR all of the states payroll all
of the state's stuff there are a lot of
other systems but it is the primary
system by which the the the uh business
entity that we call the State of New
Hampshire operates we run it through a
division that's called financial data
management it's a misleading name for
the division because it's not just
financial data but still it's there in
the IT world everything is moving to the
cloud uh there are reasons for that that
make it simple um it's very important
that we stay upgraded in New Hampshire
we didn't for 20 years we sort of
ignored every upgrade and and in the
early to mid 2000s we had a system that
was um held together with bailing wire
and paper clips and there was like three
people who knew how it worked um and
there was a danger that they might
retire um and that's not a situation to
be in so we try to keep upgrade when you
go to the cloud the upgrades happen
easier rather than
catastrophic um giant disruption to
business um it had this fairly high on
their list because um we should have
gone to the cloud years ago and the
money is not there it's it's uh it's $5
million it would last a long time it
would require an enormous amount of work
by everybody in the state's accounting
staff in every department and everybody
on the state's HR staff in every
department but it's critical to the
functionality of the system and if we
don't do it we will eventually
be a I don't want to say a second class
citizen because it's not like we're
running first class stuff it's it's this
is a good program but it's um you know
it's not a Cadillac it's just a nice
Chevy um but we want to keep keep a nice
Chevy and I don't want to start driving
a Yugo um that's not a good explanation
and and Alex would be very disappointed
at my description but it's very uh it's
very important to the to the financial
and and HR System of the state that we
go that we go to the cloud and we can't
do it without spending a modest amount
of money although I know $5 million
sounds like a lot and Karen's gonna go
what do you mean modest it's $5 million
I could do like 106 roofs but that's
where we
stand questions commission
this I do have one
commissioner um I agree that if
something we need to
do um is are we talking a multi bium
project with this um so could is this
just the first down payment is this the
total amount and if it's the total
amount could we split it between two
bium in order to do another leaky roof
somewhere
um you know it's a good question I I
don't
think the the the problem is that um a
lot of the costs are going to happen in
the banum will it leech over into a
third year yes there some of the um some
of the implementation cost will leech
over into a third year not a significant
portion of them um
and we have to
commit we have to um once once we commit
we're committed if you know what I mean
we have to either do the whole thing or
not do it at all and and the danger with
not doing it in one budget is that
um you you quite we have to sign a
contract we're gonna have to sign a
contract for this amount um because we
we're signing a contract saying you know
we're gonna we're going to do the whole
project um and uh well and we literally
can't sign a contract if the money's not
there so um uh you know in for infor is
the name of the company they're not
going to say well do the first half and
then let's just talk about it in in in
12 months mon so it it isn't it even
though it takes a while it's not the
kind of project that you can um what's
the word I'm looking for it's not
scalable if you know what I mean so I
kind of don't think we can I I will I
will go back and see if there's some
ability to do that but I'm I'm worried
that we uh that we literally can't
commit unless we commit to the whole
thing
sorry representative Thompson um
I see in
uh Section 8 the governor's bill here
the governor's budget um cloud services
there5 million under the department of
Information
Technology are these two not
overlapping they um they are they are
not overlapping I I'm going to be honest
I don't I don't know that particular
project but I think it's
um how do I put this um cloud services
Everything is Everything is Going to the
quote unquote Cloud um a lot of your the
data on your phone is on the cloud for
example if if you have if you take
pictures with your phone I don't want to
presume anything but if you take
pictures with your phone and a lot of
people do most of those pictures are
stored on the cloud so it doesn't clog
up your phone um and around the state
there are uh I'm going to say dozens but
probably more than dozens of systems so
while the system I'm talking about is um
I would describe as the the skeletal
backbone of the state's computer system
because it's how we run
operations there's a many multi-million
dollar system at HHS that runs um uh
Medicaid there are actually there
probably six or seven multi-million
dollar systems at HHS that run this or
that or the other thing they're
internally we have a uh we have a
separate computer system for Cost
Containment which is small we have a
larger computer system to manage um
maintenance projects micromain I think
it's called which is which Karen
overseas and other things like that what
what D what it is trying to do is is to
move as much data as they can to the
cloud and provide services for those but
none of that's related to New Hampshire
first so there's so there isn't
overlap it's just that the name is the
name signifies a type of thing you're
doing where your
data is so when I say we're moving we're
moving uh uh New Hampshire first to the
cloud it's not about that it's not just
about um disaster recovery and and the
fact that your data is stored in a place
that can't get struck by lightning
because it's in six places and one of
them's under underground in a mountain
in New York um it's that we're making a
significant uh generational upgrade to
the system and that's one thing um it's
not just about where the data is stored
I don't know if that
helps um I understand that and I
understand that we probably have a
number of different systems within the
state but it seems like if we're going
to
spend 85 million dollar just on these
two divisions of the state there must be
others that are going to ask for similar
funds is there not a way to gather all
these together and and accumulate some
sort of
savings I compiling all I I think that
if you'll recall to what uh commissioner
gay was talking about this morning is
that he does work over all all that and
he did provide us with a sheet that
showed how much was going into e agency
for it things um I'll make sure you get
it but if you have a question of that I
think that the question should go to uh
commissioner goule on the inter
relationship of those two especially
those two items and whether or not those
overlap or or whatever and I think that
if you could do that and share it with
the committee I would appreciate it
thank you thank
you any other questions on um the
financial data management I know you've
been working on this for a while
commissioner forever I think I think it
is uh General Services great thank you
um so General Services is another group
of buildings that fall under the
division of plant property um General
Services has the rest of the office
buildings in conquered um so Hazen Drive
is included there um downtown um and a
few other buildings that are kind of
scattered around um the first project
HHS roof replacement so that is the 2729
he and drive building um that houses
doit HHS and um Environmental Services
um I don't think I have to go into too
much detail on roofs we have a lot of
roofs um and anyone that have made this
list definitely have uh their fair share
of leaks um item two is a mechanical
replacement project for that same
building again this was um another uh
project that um is beginning now that we
have some Capital funding for um we have
uh enough funding to do three out of the
five air handling units um and none of
the controls so this this additional
money would allow us to finish that
project um item three uh is the tank
removal underground storage tank removal
so um Dees would like to see all
underground storage tanks removed and
replaced with above above ground tanks
because it's the safer thing to do um as
I mentioned in the courts project
sometimes there's just not the
availability to put that on um any
location on the property and so we have
to use the underground but these uh the
ones at Morton John and Johnson um and
HHS are older tanks that um
potentially could be could could become
compromised um so we'd like to remove
those um item four is a variety of um
mechanical Replacements and repairs
again um sometimes with the smaller
mechanical projects just like we saw
with the smaller roof projects we tend
to combine those into one larger project
um which allows us a little bit more
flexibility in terms of whether one
building comes in over or under um
budget um again uh Spalding
hbac um a lot of our buildings have uh
30 plus year old mechanical equipment
that is just kind of limping along and
um needs to be replaced so Spalding is
another um old Hospital campus Building
that is currently occupied by the
Department of Labor
um and then number six the Supreme Court
also has um I I believe a very old hvic
equipment this has been a request that
has been in um at least since 2007 I
believe and it finally made made the
governor's cut so that makes me very
happy to see um but again a lot of our
equipment is just very outdated and
limping along and at risk of failing at
any time so um those were the six
projects that made the list here for
General services and I'd be happy to
take questions on any of
those question from the
committee no hand H representative
Newman
unmute yourself
please represent okay here I here I am
Karen a question for you you just you
just mentioned about the underground
tanks that you like to get them gone but
in the I believe it was the first
presentation the Lebanon tank that is
still going to be an underground
tank yes the the the piece of land that
the building is on is such that there's
no place to put an above ground tank
that is large enough to run the building
we like to get a building at least two
weeks on a tank of oil because um if
there's any disruption in the supply
chain in terms of getting um heating oil
to the site um we like to have at least
two weeks of of oil kind of on standby
so that we can run the facility and so
there's nowhere um available on that
piece of property that we can put a tank
that size we're currently I think I
mentioned using an above ground tank
that's very small and it has to filled
at least once a week so it's it's not
ideal okay thank
you any further questions on
this seeing Statewide
emergency great so um we've requested
$1.5 million for the Statewide emergency
fund that's a fund that's managed by my
office as well
the funding there is available for any
State Building to utilize if they have
an emergency situation um I do have just
a few notes on things that we've done in
the past year or so um with that funding
um we've used it to repair um the sewer
line in the archives building that broke
underneath the building
um so that as you can imagine was a
project where we had to get creative and
get in there and kind of dig it out and
replace it um a bird infestation at the
prison property um and also for um
components for fire alarm um that were
damaged at one of the rest areas um by a
lightning strike so it's things that
happen unexpectedly or untimely things
that happen that we can't wait uh for
the next round of capital budget money
to um to fix them and a lot of times an
agency will come to me and say hey I
have um you know for example on the on
the rest area project I have $10,000 but
I really don't have any more than that
can you Pony up another 10 so we can get
this project going and completed ASAP
and so we tend to um you know try to
split things with agencies so that we
know that it really is an urgent
situation and they're not just coming to
us for
funding
questions Mr chairman yes
thank you and thank you for committing
the question so is there I can see the
definite need to have that Reserve um is
is there a balance in that Reserve
today there's about
$700,000 dollars remaining in the um
there's several accounts that are still
open because um they kind of roll from
year to year so the in the most recent
one that we received there's about
$700,000 remaining in that fund
thank
you any other questions about the
emergency uh
funding repres Thompson
um what's the worst case scenario you've
had that in a given
year um
that's a good question I mean I've been
managing it just for a few years so I I
can't go way way back um certainly um
you know that broken sewer pipe that was
a few hundred, do that we had to spend
out of there I think it was between two
and
300,000 um we do have a million dollar
deductible on our insurance policy um so
if we were had to have like a major um
complete loss of a building um it would
be good to have at least a million
dollars available to be able to rebuild
um especially if it was a a building
that we well all of our buildings
critical we're kind of bursting at the
seam so um to go without a building
would be really would be a really tough
thing to do so I I think this is Charlie
I think there was a a situation that you
know Karen talks about things like you
know the bird infestation and if you've
ever had a bird infestation you know how
bad those can be um it's not the birds
themselves it's what they leave behind
um the uh so that those things tend to
be smaller you know we think at the
veterans home which was hund and
something thousand and and there tend to
be a lot of those over the course of
although we've done really well during
the pandemic frankly um but every now
and again something really big happens
and and we had probably here before my
time but um something like eight to 10
years ago graphic Services had a huge
problem uh the the warehouse down on on
Sor Street or or Hills depending on how
you count um by The Market Basket
downtown um and it was multiple millions
of dollars and because of the nature of
the problem our
insurance didn't cover it at all so it
wasn't like we had to we were only
responsible for the first million so
that happens on occasion but you know as
Karen said it's typically not not uh the
worst case scenario is typically a a lot
of little ones and um and we use it I
want to make sure people understand this
that Karen administers it um but it's
not just for or or nor is there a
preference for buildings that are
managed by Das so Corrections is where a
lot of things happen and technically
they manage their own buildings but they
have an equal claim to the
phone thank you H thank you commissioner
I was just going to mention about that
warehouse because I was here with to
find the money to do that we did not
have an emergency f that point um so it
made it a
little more of a challenge shall I say
because we did need to get it fix any
other questions on the emergency fund
representative AB yes thank you Mr
chairman um where would would conquered
steam would that fall into one of these
categories or that was just completely
separate thing we were doing Capital
bu um are you referring to the the steam
boiler replacement project where we had
to install yes okay um so in Charlie can
chime in if I missed something but there
was about $2 million that lapsed in the
original appropriation for that uh steam
conversion project which left us $2
million short to complete the final um
boiler installations um and piping that
needed to be done to get all of the
buildings online with heat um so we we
have used some emergency funds for that
we've also used a fund that we have
called the maintenance fund which comes
um all of the well not the courts but
the other two groups of buildings the
ban buildings and the general Services
building pay a a small incremental fee
on their per square foot charge that
they pay to us to maintain and operate
the buildings um which goes into a
maintenance fund which is used to um do
deferred maintenance proess some of that
money was also used to fill that Gap um
where the $2 million had lapsed so um
between those two sources we've um
assuming everything comes in on budget
we have filled that that $2 million gap
I I want to add add something to that
just for for people who know that the
the replacement of conquered steam when
when when conquered steam decided to
shut down and I think we're even tearing
the building down now uh which is a bit
of a nightmare um was it $27 million
project that
involved I don't know something like 18
separate projects boiler here a boiler
there you know something in the up and
Walker house something different for the
Annex in the State House some a third
thing for the L Etc and then all kinds
of stuff on the campus and South Street
everywhere else um it's a $27 million
project a portion of that was a capital
appropriation um a smaller I want to say
something like seven million and the
chunk a big big chunk of it was in a
bill passed in the in the spring of
2017 um where they took uh you know
unexpected windfall or strong tax
revenues and they just paid it um they
didn't pay it they set it aside um for
us to spend the money on the project
took forever and it it's actually really
fast given what we were doing but it
seems like forever because we're still
you know just finishing it and there's
some you know we're Loose Ends thing but
the fact that I'm sitting in the annex
right now and it's warm suggest that we
were successful um but and the whole
project is going to come in almost right
exactly at budget I mean we might be a
you know even a couple of hundred grand
short which is astonishing that you
because you can't predict that I mean
that's ridiculous it's I mean it's it's
either Mike Conor is brilliant or it's
dumb loock or maybe a combination of
both but um at the end of last session
we' gotten the project extended and
there was language in in House Bill 2
and all of that and because we we had
you know $2 million left to spend
because this was taking a while this was
taking a while and then the bill that in
which it got extended there was a
continuing resolution maybe you remember
that um we remembered intensely um and
then the bill that extended the funding
got vetoed and we get a call from the
governor's office saying because it was
one of those bills with 800 things in
them and we were just sort of on the
edge and chump Chang
and not chump change but you know it was
all a fight over something else and they
said you're going to have to figure
something out you know don't stop doing
the steam project figure something out
and so this is where Karen I I said
before Karen's the smart one um she and
her people figured it out and we you
know we uh you know R Peter to pay Paul
and a little bit of money here a little
bit of money there and managed to get it
done a little bit with emergency funds
but in the end very little and the
maintenance fund which was meant for
other things but we had to use for this
so um got it done some extra money was
needed but it wasn't really extra money
it was money that went away that wasn't
supposed to and we're going to come in
under
budget
yay any other questions on Where were we
oh Statewide emergency Statewide energy
yes so the last um group that falls
under me is the state energy manager's
office um which I believe was
established in uh 2005 um I used to be
the state energy manager I did that for
nine years before doing this um so it's
near and dear to my heart um every by
anym we asked for just a little bit of
money to do some energy conservation
projects um the money that we get we we
turn around and give right back to the
state because we um invest in things
like energy efficient lighting uh
boilers building controls weatherization
things that save the state money so
um if this million dollars were to get
approved it would be invested in things
that would um you know have Energy
savings and and pay itself back over
time um guess that's all I have to say
about that we do use it in all any state
any state-owned building is eligible
just like with the emergency fund to
apply for energy funds in the past we've
used several different um techniques to
kind of distribute the money I think
Charlie and I talked about um you know
this with this million dollars let's
let's do the the best bang for our buck
kind of projects regardless of what
building or where it is so I think
that's what we're looking to do this
year and get the uh the state the most
energy savings that we
can today this morning at fiscal
committee um we were asked about an item
that's tangentially related to this
about a Federal grant for for energy
projects and it's it's the same kind of
thing I mean it's the same thing
different money um it's 40 grand um and
somebody said what do you get for that
and I said it's not that complicated
actually lower electric bills period we
do stuff we spend less electricity like
when you change out your light bulbs and
we save
money there was a press release that
came out last week and it it has more
detail on this and over the course of
the um existence of the state energy
manager Office we've avoided around $45
million in energy cost for the state
any questions on this I not
representative
a yes thank you Mr chairman um I noticed
in the Blue Book the request for this
fund was $
2,900,000
and the governor has put it down there's
a
million I uh
it's funny I thought we requested um
yeah that sounds right so we there's a
lot of stuff that could be fixed the
state's buildings are you know kind of
rough and um you it's one of those
things if you buy a house that was built
in
2010 probably not a lot you can do for
Energy Efficiency if you buy an old
Victorian probably a lot you can find um
and we got a lot of old victorians in
the state and so we got a lot of stuff
to fix so we asked for
we asked for money we asked for a good
amount of money and I think the governor
looked at it uh I think the governor
thinks a little bit like representative
Gram's earlier question about scaling
something back and he went yeah I want
to do that but you know do what you can
with uh with this much instead of uh as
much as you want and if you give us more
we'd do more if you give us less we do
less uh thank you chairman uh actually I
put my hand up right when um uh
representative Abbott started talking I
and I took it down because it was the
same basically the same question I was
going to ask and but I was gonna I could
ask further is there any feel for how
much money we would get back um between
possible uh Federal uh reimbursements or
matching funds or because you had
mentioned that you felt we saved uh $45
million over a period of years uh is
there any feel for the payback on on
this type of
investment sure so um the kind of the
rule of thumb that I used to use when I
was in that role was uh a 10year payback
is good for the state so there was a lot
of projects that were under that so some
were five some were two um meaning if
you invest um $100,000 that you're going
to get $50,000 a year in Energy savings
so in two years you'll get your $100,000
back um somewhere a little bit higher
but if we are in a situation where we
need to replace a boiler because it's
failing or failed it makes sense at that
point in time to purchase the more
expensive energy efficient unit because
it's going to be in our building for for
a long time and so some of the projects
were a little higher some were under and
um on average we were running like six
to seven years on the payback um
additionally we do have the opportunity
to apply for and reinvest um incentives
and rebate so any project that we do we
also apply to the utilities um or the
Public Utilities Commission or both
depending on what type of project it is
and if we are able to get an incentive
that gets redeposited into the energy
investment fund which can then be used
to reinvest in our state facilities to
do more energy saving
projects if I could have a followup
certainly thank you um when uh I've been
involved in these type of programs to
review Energy Efficiency in school
systems then we would prioritize
according to the
payback um on which projects we would do
first and and and it really helped uh
but after you go expend a certain amount
then you obviously getting into ones
that have less priority and is less
payback so if we right now it's been cut
from the 2.9 Million down to a million
is there any feel for the way the
priorities are set up of how much you
would save if let's say you you got
another million this
year um so one of the ways that we
decide what types of projects or what
projects we're going to do is every year
each agency that owns property is
required to do evaluate their facilities
and submit a list of energy saving
projects that they could do in their
facilities um we ask them also to
estimate a cost and um an energy savings
from that project um again just like
with the um capital budget submittal
process those numbers can sometimes just
be very back of the envelope um but we
take all of that information and we
um we put it all together and we um
submit a report every year that says
here's all the things that we could do
in state buildings if we had unlimited
funds
um and then over the course of you know
when we do get funding over the course
of the the bium we decide um which
projects are really feasible sometimes
an agency might go forward and do a
project on their own because it's like I
said if it's a boiler that's failed yeah
they might want to do it as an energy
project but they might just need to get
it done also and they might fund it some
other way go through that list and we do
we we tend to pick um the projects with
the best payback um but also the
projects that we don't think agencies
are going to be able to do on their own
um so if it's a very small investment um
with a very quick payback we might just
say hey take some operating funds spend
the $5,000 you're going to get it back
in a year or two anyway with the same
savings um so I would say um with a
million dollars I think we could Target
probably that six to seven year payback
and as you said like then it kind of
gets incrementally um higher beyond that
but I I do think that everything that we
do would still average out to 10 years
or less thank you I I would say just to
so people kind of understand how this
work sometimes I um you can kind of see
behind me a window and then there's
another one over here um um my office
gets really really cold and uh and um
Karen is very unsympathetic to me um I'm
just saying out loud um but it and
because the windows are drafty is all
get out and you know I sit my chair is
near the window I think I need to change
that but um and I said something once
about aren't windows don't we isn't that
a good thing to like fix and we got to
be spending all kinds of money on heat
because of the air blowing in on me and
um and in part cuz she's fairly brutal
this way in evaluating things she said
yeah Windows aren't a good
payback so my windows have not been
replaced because apparently windows are
not a good payback so I say that to say
that we are routinely evaluating what's
a good payback and what isn't and even
if your your whiny boss complains to you
about Windows he doesn't get
them commissioner can we quote you at
HHS or others come in wanting to replace
windows I uh uh yeah no
maybe
um any questions on the Statewide
energy commissioner I do have one
request the the question came up about
the Statewide emergency
fund if you could provide us or Karen
more likely uh provide us with what's
been appropriated the last couple bi
enums of where the money went and what
left before we decide whether to give
you you know half a million a million
whatever in this
one helpful just to see where where it
is hopefully we'll never have that
warehouse situation yet KN on
wood um we can provide that and uh would
it be helpful if we send it to Mr Shay
yes it would okay
okay this went than I
thought that's what I like to hear any
other questions to the
commissioner um or or admin Services um
overall at this point in the
process representative Thompson what is
the what's the benefit of a million
dollar
million dollars the insurance company
the that we have to pay first what
what's the cost as opposed to having a
half it's a good question we we evaluate
our our coverage
regularly and
um uh so broadly speaking on
insurance um
think of it this way for everybody to
some extent insurance is meant to be for
for your house for anything is meant to
be sort of stoploss coverage you're
going to do the little stuff and you're
going to make sure they have the big
stuff so that you know you pay for the
doctor's checkup they pay for the heart
attack you know that kind of stuff too
but um and on insurance you look at it
because if you have a $500,000
deductible you know our premium is going
to be higher if you have a million
dollar deductible our premium is going
to be a little lower then the question
you have to ask yourself is can we
afford as a as an entity
the risk at my house we have a
relatively low deductible certainly not
a million dollars um I don't think it's
that low but um um because you know we
can't you know we don't have we don't
have money set aside we we self-insure
on health insurance because the state
can absorb the ups and downs and and ins
and outs particularly over time um a
million dollars was set a long time ago
as a decent number it went up when it
went up from 500 to a million I think um
they calculated the savings as
relatively extraordinary and realized we
weren't getting much we've talked
internally recently this is not not
Karen's area but risk and benefits um
what we used to call risk management who
who does the insurance buying and one of
the things we've looked at is you know a
couple of questions one should the state
just be entirely self-insured on
buildings and not have any insurance
coverage whatsoever on the assumption
that we can afford it probably not we
can't afford that much like we couldn't
afford 10 million is a million the right
number is two million the right number
and one of the things that we're going
to do is when our policies are up is
we're going to price various levels
what's a million what's two million
what's three million and then look at
our claims history and how many how many
claims do we have the truth is we
haven't really had many claims because
we don't hit that number very often or
when we do the insurance company has a
way like they did at graphic services to
not really cover it so um what's the
benefit it's it's how much risk we can
absorb the emergency fund is the way we
uh absorb the risk of having an a
million dollar policy um but it's
something that we have to evaluate and
we'll probably be be doing over the next
nine months as to whether that number is
too low
right thank you representative
Newman yes thank you there was a um a
comment uh Karen you made it early on
about roofs and that quite often roofs
can be overestimated under budgeted
whatever and and you were trying to uh
um you know put a a a pile of money
together hopefully hopefully that they
would cover the roofs as needed do you
all look at different materials for
roofs or are all the buildings roofs a
standard um I'm I'm I'm asking if you'd
use metal roofs at all if you've got any
um comparisons that some roofs would
give you a better bang for your
buck a great question um we have all
different kinds of roofs in the state
and not a lot of metal ones that I know
of um especially at Das possibly on the
do side they might have some but
um you know we have membrane roofs the
kind that have the stone on top we have
like a typical like New England pitched
roofs that have shingles we have slate
roofs so we have a whole bunch of
different kinds of roofs um we do look
at different options so certainly when
we're replacing a slate roof a lot of
times we just can't afford to put slate
on again so we do some sort of imitation
slate that maybe really looks nice um
but the the interesting thing that we
noted was you know a few years ago when
we bid out some roofs they all came in
over budget and so I'm thinking oh
Roofing has really gone you know through
the roof um in terms of pricing but then
the next round of roofs went out and
they came in right on budget and it it
it's it's just a funny thing that it
depends on the complexity of the roof
the location um the condition and the
material so all those things kind of
factor in and um Public Works does a
great job at estimating but sometimes
when they're estimating stuff um 18 or
20 months before the project actually
happens a lot can change in the in the
economy and and and in resources and in
and um you know Manpower too like
sometimes it's hard to just find a
contractor and prices go up so it's it's
just one of those things that it's
really just hard to predict um
year-over-year what you're going to see
for pricing we had a lot of roof issues
about a year and a half ago and we did a
we did a bunch of looking into it for um
you know Public Works was doing this
because we and you might know that
there's a school of thought that says
that we estimate everything too high and
come in under budget and there's another
school of thought I had a I had about
nine months ago I had two meetings in a
row in the same week anyway where where
the one guy said you guys way
overestimate everything and then
somebody else said you know what the
problem is everything you estimate is
underestimated and I thought well those
can't both be right and the truth is
they are both right we estimate as best
we can but you can't predict markets and
things like that we looked at roofs
because we were having problems like
Karen talked about um and and one of our
guys I think Ted did this went out and
talked to a couple of contractors and
said said you know let me buy a cup of
coffee and um talk to me about this and
the one guy said I don't want to do the
project State projects are hard to do
anyway because the state is UN
complicated so okay I get that that's
probably not going to change that much
um because of some of our you know the
rules and regulations and and and uh
Protections in place
but he said we got a lot of business
right now and I don't want to do any but
if you're going to throw money at me
I'll do it so I hate Roofing projects
and nobody likes it and apparently
Roofing is not something a lot of people
like to do um in in the trades um and he
said uh but so you're gonna put
something out to bid and I'm thinking
could I do it for 150 Grand yeah I don't
want to I'm gonna throw a bid in at 350
which is ridiculous
but I don't want the business but if
you're G to give me 350 I'll take the
business and so that that ends up
happening the combination or combining
things part of the help that that uh is
is somebody goes do I want to go through
all of this hassle for a project that is
100 grand and I'm G to net like 500
bucks on no but if you're G to let me do
a million dollars worth of roofing
projects my Net's going to be greater
and I'm willing to absorb some of the
hassle so sometimes we'll bid things out
multiple ways that way but it's a lot of
times it's about the market you know
when the when the market was so good
just think of you know a little more
than a year ago there are a lot of
people who are like you know I got all
the business I need and so I'm biding
high on everything if I get it I get it
if I don't I don't
um you know the people will tell you in
the middle of a recession sometimes you
get a better you get better prices so
yeah it's hard to
know thank
you I see no other hands raised I I
would like to mention one thing um
commissioner kept holding up this uh the
the CIP I I would
suggest that as we're going through
agencies such as uh admin administrative
services that have multiple projects
that you have that somewhere close
because each of these lines they have a
page or more of what exactly what the
project is so that we can look at it and
when it says multiple roots for the
court system it lays out the court the
courts that they are looking at doing
they may not get them all if they can't
get tce but at least it gives you a feel
for what they're saying and um
especially since we're trying to do
things via zoom and we don't always have
the uh the time that we would have if we
were in here every day in our own road
to question people it would be helpful
and I just make that
suggestion anything else for the
commissioner uh representative edar uh
thank you Mr chairman well speaking of
uh
Court I had a question on the uh
Rochester Circuit Courthouse the one
that you'd put in for over 15
million um a lot of money and they see
it's been pulled but uh it also mentions
in there that you don't have the land
yet or the price doesn't include the
land do you actually have the the site
for it
already no we don't we um this is
something that the city of Rochester was
interested in um pursuing because
they're interested in our current
building um for City use um they have a
piece of land available that we could
negotiate um in terms of you know make
that part of the deal in terms of if we
sell our facility to them and and and we
think that the land that they have is
appropriate um we could certainly work
that in
um we've built a lot of cour houses um
in the past few years um I I don't want
to overstep but I don't think this is
something that necessarily came from Das
I think it came from the judicial branch
um and like I said initiated by the city
of Rochester so if it if it were to make
it into the budget we would certainly
run with it and get it done um I guess I
guess that's what we have to say about
that I think I think there were concerns
and a number of people had concerns
about the land uh the question about the
land and some of the other questions and
you know where do where do we want
Rochester to be at the end of the day
and and is it a is it a priority
um I uh I'll just say this m so we had a
meeting and and and Ted really didn't
Ted from public works when we were
evaluating things said well they don't
have the land yet and I thought I
thought if the projects approv they'll
get the land they're probably not going
to get the land if they're not going to
build a courthouse and you know what you
can argue that both ways right uh well
don't come to us until you have the land
and then Rochester is thinking well why
am I going to buy land if I'm not going
to build a courthouse and and you can
argue it both ways but I think in the
end um while I am not as uh hyper about
whether they have the land in in front I
think that's probably a a reason that it
was not well shall we say didn't make
the
cut plus we built a lot of cour houses
the last couple
years if I could follow up please follow
um well yeah thank you for building one
uh close to here in Hampton we
appreciate it um but the question H have
uh it lists here in the reasoning that
there's a security problem there is
there a severe security problem at the
present
uh Courthouse
there I can speak to older buildings
that were not originally built to be
cour houses um all have security
problems based on our current standard
um recently there was a court and
plastow that was closed as you may know
um things like not having separate
entrances for inmates that come in um
not having steel doors and the holding
cells where inmates are held prior to
traal um
uh things like that so I don't know
specifically what is happening at
Rochester I can find out for you um but
my guess is because it was an older
building not originally intended to be
used as a courthouse that there probably
are certainly some security concerns
there are um court court facilities un
unlike executive and legislative branch
facilities where you know they're a
little bit Loosey Goosey on um Court
facilities has an accreditation
committee there's a formal process
there's a there's a a committee is
chaired by the the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court um uh Karen and I go and
and um Sarah linbury who's the head of
Court facilities practically runs it but
she presents on on facilities court
security on that uh there are
legislative members or there are public
members and they look at all the cour
houses to see if they meet certain
standards plastow was closed the first
one in a long time because it was you
know they're holding as a closet I mean
literally a closet and so at some point
people are like you know what we can't
do this um Rochester is not at that
point where there's an operational issue
but if you were looking at our
facilities um and you said you know you
think of the the the more modern
buildings in in in Hampton and Milford
that we built recently and the and the
and the one over in in conquer um there
are a lot of uh you know thoughts about
you know who crosses paths with who and
and holding cells and and all that kind
of stuff and they're very modern they're
all kinds of guidelines this wasn't
built according to those guidelines are
they making the best of it yeah is it is
it a problem from an accreditation
standpoint where at any time something
might happen and we have like a Jack
Ruby situation no so um that's a way of
saying it's it's not great and it's not
uh so horrible that they have to close
it down or it definitely would have made
the cut thank you
any other
questions if not commissioner thank you
very much for coming in today um we
appreciate it and I am sure that some
point the next month there'll be other
questions that be answered
um we're here to answer any questions
you want and uh Ted and Michelle will be
available to answer any questions on the
estimate and how on Earth we got there
and if you have anything particularly
hard um and you call me I'll just talk
to Karen and she can answer in other
words call car first sounds good I'm not
saying that's a bad
idea thank you for us thank you so
much all right for the
committee um we have two days of session
next week right down the street from my
house no would not
to but I hope that um I see as many of
you as possible be there it's going to
be a couple of Fairly long days um we
are up against the deadline uh for early
bills um which we have to get through
either Wednesday or Thursday at the
latest um right now I have not heard of
any of the three bills we have on Cent
calendar being pulled off so we keep
that um going I hope and then next
Friday um we will meet again for
presentations um and this is going very
well um and I I appreciate that and if
anybody would like to ask questions
please you know raise your hand while
we're going through and we'll get them
answered but don't feel bad about
reaching back out either myself Mr Shay
or um any of the agencies to get
additional information if you you have
questions about a
specific um project that that you're
interested in or concerned about because
at the end of the day we're going to
have to agree to a uh capital budget for
the house to vote on has been the
tradition of this um committee that we
have come out unanimously with with what
we propos and it sails through the house
usually out a Voice vote um which for
you know $130 million is a bad um
especially um some of the members but it
helps if we can both sides can sell it
to their cognizes so we will continue to
work on it I know that Mr Shay and um
legisl uh legislative Services is
working on drafting
hp25 and as soon as that comes out um
we'll get everybody copy um but again
it's just a matter of time and putting
it into the right format for for a bill
anybody have any questions of me Mr
chairman you
said okay thank you Mr chairman you sent
us out an email early this week saying
that after next week's hearing the next
two
presentation actually it's going to be a
presentation but the
next would could be Hybrid next week but
the following the the ones in early
March of schedu are going to be all
virtual that that is my plan right now
for after next Friday we still have two
essentially two days worth of
presentations by
agencies as you may have noticed looking
at the house calendar it gets tight in
the lob for for scheduling all 20
committees um and other committees are
are have a deadline of mid-march while
our is at the end of March um but we can
do the
presentations
remotely um you're GNA get the same
thing from the agency whether you're
sitting in this room or you're sitting
at home as far as looking at a screen
and what they're bringing up or what you
have on your desk um
so I have been in discussions with the
speaker's office about doing the rest of
the presentations at after next Friday
fully remote and then a couple of days
in a hybrid with as many as want to be
in here in here to um do a work session
to come up with an amendment to House
Bill 25 and then an executive session on
hus Bill 25 we can get almost all of our
work done in work sessions on um um what
we've heard and what we would like to
see in each of the agencies and once
that Amendment is done the vote is
usually pretty um quick in an exec
session because we've already talked it
out and conducted straw Poes on e agency
as we've gone through the the work
sessions for those of you who have been
around that's the way it's worked and
it's worked well for the news people all
abouts evolved um because we are up
against deadlines and whereas in the
past um the chair had the option of just
saying okay we're going to meet Tuesday
Wednesday um in room 201 for a couple of
three hours I don't have that option um
this year so um it will make a little
longer days I fully expected that this
afternoon would have gone a little
longer there weren't a lot of questions
about um the projects from admin
services I don't know if that's because
the commission and Karen put put words
in in the right order or what but I do
that representative Newman yes thank you
thank you I uh representative Peterson
and myself were talking earlier do you
have any update on how Mr fidelia is
doing no I do not I got an email last
night saying that um there was a family
emergency and that came in to let
legislative Services commun Services
upstairs and not to me it was forwarded
to me um so that was last night I don't
have an update on on how Jim is doing
okay thank
you and and so another thing Mr chairman
just to clarify we will also have to
have a formal public hearing on house
bille 25 where you will introduce it and
anybody have a beef or a complaint
probably that's there will be a formal
public hearing on House Bill 25 live um
my intent is to do at least one of the
work sessions here from U from all of us
on where we think we're going um and
then open a public hearing on what the
go it will be at that point what the
governor
propose um although people hopefully
will have listened to what we're
thinking about and then after the public
Heary another shorter work session to
develop the final Amendment um taking
into consideration what the public has
weighed in on as far as um their desires
for Capital Improvements within the
state because that is important um again
that will be a hybrid meeting all the
meetings for commities are going to be
either fully remote or or hybrid not
just this one but all of of course we
have to deal with the lab State
extensions and
representative working on getting handle
a when to do that representative Mills I
signed you up for that subcommittee
um and uh there'll be like four or five
people on that which is good and that's
important because as you saw from what
the um Veterans Home put out you know we
have completed these projects there's
money left over if there's significant
money left over maybe we can fund a
different project or add to another
project that got curtailed by the
governor and and it's worked out um last
a year ago and one of the last things
that we voted on um
and one of the oous bills from the
Senate um the several projects have been
completed since House Bill 25 been
passed and there was well over $2
million left to complete something that
we had shorted the the
PR technical education School in Hudson
so they were able to get that money for
them
soon I would have liked to have had it
this side but we still would have had to
pay CTE in Hudson but that's what we try
to do and I know representative Jack has
worked on that before and we shall see
how much we can find or
not will be completely remoted not not
in
up and again thank you very much for re
updating everybody well you know the
problem is that you don't update people
I'm GNA get the phone calls and emails
yeah I was just trying to help you no it
is and from time to time the speaker
will talk about sessions are going to be
and the rest and I will make sure that I
get that out to uh members of the
committee for planning purposes
of Representative m
yes thank you Mr chair well I just had
uh one question that's been bugging me
since uh we we had the initial
presentation from the governor's office
and I didn't want to bring it up until
we were all just in in Committee hearing
um was I to understand that the the gray
Governor's capital budget book we've got
actually even though it's it's listed
for
$127 million general fund budget
it has $2 and A5 million dollar in out
of that figure that they don't need the
Hudson CTE Center if you'll
remember Matt May did go when he was
talking he said
125 he gave a figure of 125 not 127 so I
think his mind he's already subtracted
that uh 2 million
so but yeah that 127 includes that 2.5
million for the CTE and Hudson so we're
we're less than that
now okay thank you well I think that at
least gives
us the idea that we might have a little
bit of leeway if the governor was was
willing to come up with
127 we might we might have some bump up
room on some things that's all I wanted
to ask about we can you know and I don't
work for the government I don't know
about
thank
you but we have to be within reason of
what we think can pass as well so I that
is really important to be able to get it
through both the house and the Senate
with relative e um and not upset the
governor so much that he'll veto or
something um I think being reasonable
and working within the guidelines that
we put out plus what we have worked on
in the past as a committee is always
useful for for guidance for us going
forward then we do have um couple of
projects that people have come in for
outside of the capital budget that we're
going to have to work on to see if we
can f the the stream Fort
digitation being the one that comes to
mind I right off
that what um What affected any is the
president's new executive order on made
America have on these projects as we go
forward your guess is as good as mine if
if
we he can't his executive order the way
I understand it is for federal agencies
Federal contracts and and I understood
it mean any state projects that use
federal money as and that maybe I was
just gonna say that so I don't know um
so we'll just have to
see and that's where um sometimes have
every project that is bid has a
contingency fund on it um just in case
some of those things do go up for
example if aluminum or Steel in the past
we've watched um construction cost rise
this commune has watched them R 10 15% a
year with concrete steel those types of
I personally just have one small water
project that is funded with Federal
money and the
difference in a day on my material cost
where I would normally buy the pipe out
of Canada it's going to cost me
$27,000 and in all honesty that's very
what we can do do at this point is go
with the best estimates that um Public
Works has given us Das Public Works pass
the budget with that there are always
projects at the next by any that we
cannot do we could not do this because
all of the bids came in
over and it's GNA happen you know do I
like it no but it's best they do the
best we do the best that we can as far
as we think this is the ballpark figure
you know and if it comes in three times
the the amount that was estimated we've
got other problems do we have the option
setting aside money no we don't not
really that's in the contract that's in
the actual contract
so and we also there's also money that
is set aside everything project for art
within the
building so we care too much with that
and David bills is
frozen I
thought oh he's back okay any other
questions or comments I Mr chairman uh
Vice chair it's
go thank you Mr chairman uh there was a
point in time a number of years ago when
there wasn't cost at least even a cost
of living built into bids and where the
10-year plan especially was so far out
by the time we got projects in mind
everything was just toly low without
funds and that was as the chairman said
where we those years we had just even
ASA in conrete jumping so much so I I
commend the services on that bidding
because they it's it's a much different
process now than it was even 10 years
ago right the only reason I raised point
was um the Commissioners pointed out
that many of these estimates they come
up with created 18
months by the time it goes through the
system we're talking two years out and
with that executive order and some of
them some of them will be
updated not so much when we have it but
when the Senate has it
sometimes the latter half of this year
um they will go you know based on
changes to Federal rules or whatever
we've got to change this and then you
got to drop
something it's a almost zero
[Music]
something anything else I appreciate
everybody hanging in um again uh see you
next week um look for the any written
material be email to you or on the LBA
web page and that will that's a starting
point for each each session and I
appreciate everybody being here today
and I hope to see most if not all of you
on Wednesday and or Thursday thank you
thank you right I think
we whoever shuts his